צ להסביר את ה
>> הגדלות של ימי
>> מוכין דקטנות
>> הגדלות של מוכין דקטנות
בחוכים חג שמח בחוץ עדו בלי מופטות בלי
כלום לא נוראותר לכם
יאללה חג שמח שו של רבון מות טובות בואו
נכתוב נכתוב האם מוכין לקטנות
זהבי
>> חיוביים או שליליים זה מה שאתם שואלים
>> חיוביים או שליים אפשרויות
אפשרויות
א'
מצב שפל
אחיזה תקלי
ב
>> מצב שפר
זון מדמ
>> מדמן מדמים מדמים דמים מדמים
>> מדמימים לכתוב
אה חמש
מצב העולמות בכריסה
העולמות בכריסה
א
ארבע חלק אלוה ממעל
אלוה ממעל
שזוכים לו יחידים
שזוכים לא יחילים
שש
כן זה שש
>> חמש
דבר עליון
דבר עליון המופיע
בתוך הפרטים
הגורם לעולם
להתעלות אז מה אתם אומרים אתם
מה אפשר מה אתם אומרים
כל זה במוחין לקטנות
קטנות כל זה מוכן קטנות
כל זה קטנות לא אמרתי מוכן לקטנות
>> קטנות מה כתוב שמה מוכנות
>> לא קטנות
>> אוקיי קטנות כתוב הגדרת קטנות הגדרת הגדרת
הקטנות
תביא
תן תמיד כע
אוקיי אז בוא נלך אחד אחד נלך אחד אחד
יאללה נחיל פה ה עמוד גמ
>> פה עמוד ג בסדר או נתחיל לפני כן נתחיל פ
נעשה פא עמוד א' אוקיי נכתוב כי פה כבר
מומחים לזה אתם כבר מומחים לזה פ עמוד א'
הכוונות הכוונות או לפני כן בוא נתחיל לעט
אבל זה סתם מסתבר
>> רואים למטה עד היינו נכתוב עד עמודה ב'
למטה
הגדרת מוחין דקטנות הגדרת מוכין דקטנות
נקרא בדברי הרב ג כלן בג
כלן בג
אוקיי קוראים עד עמוד ב
תכתבו עד עמוד ב
מוכין בקטנות תכתוב
עד עמודה ג
עד עמודה ג מוכין לקטנות
נקרא
עיבור והניקה שם אלוה
שם אלוהים
אנחנו אומרים עכשיו לדף פ
עמודה ג פ עמודה ג
פ עמוד ג נכתוב מוכן לקטנות
מוכין לקטנות
שייכים לעיבור ויניקה
לעיבור וניקה
וכל חול
זכנו
בפסח ספירת העומר שבוע
ובמוכין לגדלות
מוכים לגדלות ולא במוחים לקטנות
אוקיי עכשיו אנחנו נמצאים בדף פא
פא עמודה א'
יב דוכמים תחילה רבי יוסף נכתוב בפסח
בגלל גלות מצרים
פסח בגלל גלות מצרים פא עמוד א' כן בגלל
גלות מצרים הזה היה במדרגה הכי שפלה
שהיא נקראת
כתנות ג כלן בג'
אוקיי אחוז בקל לי
ואני אתם רואים מה שקרדנו בהתחלה צנו
עכשיו פ עמודה ג
פ
עמודה ג נכתוב בפסח
זה היה בגדלות
אחרי פסח מסתלקים המוחים
וחוזר למצב
הכי שפל
שהוא
מוכין
דקטנות
והזון
מדמים. בסדר? דמים יש גם בזה, גם בנוקבה
יש דמים. אוקיי, סגור.
פב עמוד הב.
פב עמוד הב. פב עמוד. תכתוב ג מצות. ג
מצות
מסמים
בוכין דקתנותן
מוכין דקטון
אלוהים דיודין הן אלפים
אלוהים דודין דעין דאלפין
אלפים
והם נקראים מוחין דעיבור
ספירת העומר
הם מתעלים למצב של יניקה
של יניקה
טוב לכן ספירתומר נקרא חגף לכן ספירתומר
נקרא חג
ובפסח
נשלמת ההקומה
בפסח נשלמת הקומה פסח
>> א בשבועות שבועות נכון בשבועות נשלמת
הקומה
לכן מתעלה הזה לחבב.
אוקיי, הגענו לדף פ ב עמודה ג.
המוחים בקטנות
צריכים טהרה.
לכן לא נמשכים בתחילה,
רק אחרי
מוכים בחוכמה.
בסדר
מוכים בחוכמה פג
פג שים סיכום פג מוכים לקטנות
אחרי שנתחרים
נאכלים
נאכלים אבל מכוח אבל מכוח
אבל מכוח אמא
מטהרת כתנות דתבונה
נכון זה נקרא אכילת כרפס
שס אכילת כרפס אוקיי בוכים באבא
בוכים באבא
מטהרים כתמו בישס
וזה נקרא מצע פרוסה
אוקיי
עכשיו הגענו לדרוש פד דף
פד אוקיי סכם לכם את כל שר הכוונות
פד עמודה א'
על ידי
כניסת המוכין אז ניגע ניגעל בא' אוקיי
ספירת העומר
ספירת העומר כניסת המוחין
מטהרת את הזה זה
שנמצא במצב של קטנות
בינים.
אוקיי,
הגענו עכשיו לדף
פה עמודה ג פה עמודה ג'
קורבן העומר.
קורבן קורבן העומר קורבן קורבן קורבן
העומר
נכון
א נתבטל היום
נתבטל היום לכן
מוכים לחסדים גבורות
לא יכולים להתפשט
והזה דה
נמצא במצב של קטנות
כדי לרומם את הזה
אנחנו משתמשים
באור המקיף עוד דקה נקרא את הכל ככה מהר
בסדר באור המקיף אולי משך אולי ימשך
משתבשים באור המקיף אולי על ידו
אולי על ידו
עם משך אור הפנימי
לכן ספירת העומר
זכר למקדש
לו עמוד הג
העיסוק ומוכין לקטנות מסוכן
נכון
כי החיצוניים הקליפה כי החיצוניים הקליפה
רוצים במוכים לקטנות יותר ממוכים לגלות
לכן משה רבנו ברא
כי כשהתעסק
במוחן בקטנו
נתגלו החטאים שלו,
נתגלו החטאים של משה,
של משה רבנו,
ועל ידיהם
רצו להתייחס ומוכרים בכתנות.
אוקיי? אותו דף פ עמודה ג
פ ג המוכים לקטנות
טוב המוכים לקטנות
נעשים על ידי קורבן העומר
ונקראים
נחש
קראים נחש
והם הגבורות
שמעביר הזה
לנוקווה
שהיא נקודה אחת.
אוקיי? מקור אחרון.
מקור אחר. מקור האחרון זה פו עמוד ד
פו עמוד ד נכתוב כל המט ימים
כל המט ימים נקראים
כתנ
כולל פסח
שבתות
>> אוקיי עד שבועות
וכל הייחודים הנעשים בימים אלה
משנה כל הייחודים הנעשים בימים אלה תכתוב
בסוגריים מצוות עונה לא ייחודים של תפילות
הלא
מצונה הם על דרך הקטן
על דרך הקטן
אוקיי פו עמוד ד למטה תלמידי רבי עקיבא
מתו
כי אם היו מוכים וקטנו
ופגע בהם מידת הדין המתגלה בקטנות
אוקיי אז בוא נקרא מהר את כל הדרשות
מהתחלה עד הסוף נעשה את זה מהר מהר בסדר
נעשה את זה מהר לא נתעכב יותר מדי רואים
עד עמוד ב
יש לכם עד עמוד ב הראשון בוא נעשה הראשון
בוא נכתוב את הראשון עד
עמודה בסדר
פה שתן זבו בוא נקרא אנחנו עט עמודה בוא
נקרא פחות רואים למטה תקראו
רואים והנה נודעשיות בלמעלה זה אחיות
החיצונים בזה ספירה חס ושלום מחמת מעשה
התחתונים הרעים הנה מסקשב מן המקום ההוא
כדי שלא יצא שבע רב אל החיצונים הוא כבר
מנן אצילות זה בתחיל הצילותו היה בלבד
מספירות שנמצא כתחז פרעה בדעת העליון ההוא
בדור ההוא חזרה לקדמותו להיותו ג כלל מג
רואים ג כלל מג שעוד דקה תראו שזה הגדרה
של כתוב הפחודה רואים זה המקור הראשון
שכתבנו עד עמודה ב עד עמודה ג סתכלו
הנה זה אחר שלא נדב צ מבת אין אמא ק תן לו
את כתן לו רמקול יאללה
>> אוקיי יש
פה נעלה מדך נו רואה אותו אומר
>> אה הנה הנה
>> תן אותו יאללה קח והנה זה המקור השני עד
עמוד ג
בסדר אז אם אתם רוצים להשאיב תשובה מה זה
קטנות צריכים להעביר את כל הכוחות האלה
בראש אם לא אתם סתם חרטידים סתם כן זה
הולכים בקטנות ככה זה ידוע מה ידוע תגיד
מה ידוע הלאה אוקיי נמשיך הלאה בסדר עדיו
כמו
המקובלים דבר ידוע עליו
תמיד אם שבר ידוע זה בעיה על בשבילי
>> נקרא שנולד ויצא מבטן עם מילה יש לו זמן
קטנות וזמן גדלות ומוכח שבכל זמן מאלו הג'
יהיו לו בחינת מוכין. גם נודע שהעריך שאי
אפשר לו לקבל המוכין אם לא עד שהתלבשו
תחילת תוכנה היא דעימה ואחר כך התלבשו
בתוכו אלא שבזמן העיבור הראשון או בזמן
הקטנות אין לו אלא נה דעימה מבחינת
חיצוניותם מלבד
>> או שזה אלוהים סגור נמשיך על טיפה
זה המצב הזה שלקנוזה יש לנו רואים דמים 10
דמים יש לנו עזה מאירים בו 10ה דמים ולמטה
גם הנקבה היא טמאה רואים דינים כתו זה
דינים זה אחיזת הקליפה רואים את זה רואים
אתם מכירים את הדרוש הזה? כן כן
>> כן
>> אוקיי נעבור לדף פ רואים פ
עמודה ד למטה רואים עמודה ב למטה רואים
רואים אז יש לנו שני עניינים ג' כלל מג
נכון ואחיזת הקליפה הפך הודה פ עמודה ג
דורש בניין
תוקף וגלות זתוקף הגדלת ז נקראים הקדמה
אחת בעניין סדר הגדולת ד דנולד
אז הוא זמן כתנותו עד היותו גדול בג שנים
בזמן הקטלות הזה ודאי שיש לו גם כן מוחים
בקטות כנב והמוכים האלו בזמן הקטלות הם
בחינת הלבושים והכלים של נימה ובתוכם
מתלבשים גם הלבושים של ני דבר וכולי הם
נכנסים
>> בתוך חזר כן ק
>> חול נכנסים לתוך זר בסוד עיבור בסוד מוכים
כתוב עדו גדול
>> בין יג שנהג שנה
ואמנם בחינת הושים הנזכרים דיני דמ בזמן
הכת הם שירות אלוהים
>> של אלוהים נכון אז יש לנו בימי ספירת אומר
אלוהים אין כזה דבר בורחים בורחים
מהאלוהים כתוב כאן בלי לברוח מהאלוהים אלא
נמצא עם הגדלות קרו
האחורים שלמה שירושים חצורים של מבחינת
האורים כתוב
באים לבשים במ
>> ואינם מתגלים בזה
לכן גם הלבושים דני דבבה הם נקראי
חיים אלוהים על שם אמא אלוהים על שם אמ
>> אוקיי היא קובעת הבן הראשון האמא קובעת
איך קראו לו הלאה נמשיך נמשיך הלאה
>> אמנם בגדות זה אז הנבושים זהמה הם יותר
פנימיים והם מבחינת שמעות שלקה כנל כי
במוח הדעת בלבד שהוא היסוד מה יש 10 דמים
והם 10 שמות בסוד האחוריים שלהם דרך זה גם
הנצח מאוד יהיו מבחינת קירים ונמצא כמה
שאמרנו להם שבגלות מצרים היו מתגלים
10עשרה דמים אלו הנה מבחינת הלבושים שבזמן
בזמן הגדלות בזמן
>> אז מה אומר הרב אומר אל תחשוב שגלות מצרים
הייתה בגלל הקטנות חס וחלילה כי אם הייתה
בגלל הקטנות היינו 860 שנה בגלות אבל בגלל
שזה לא היה המצב בגלות מצרים אלא היה בהקה
לכן היינו 210 שנים רואים זאת אומרת
שאנחנו לא מתעסקים בקטנות לפי מה שכתוב
כאן פ עמוד ג לא מתעסקים בקטנות זה רוע
רוע אם הם מתסים בקטנות זה המצב הכי שפל
רואים פה
אוקיי
שם
>> נמצא על כגלות במצרים הזמן גדלות זה ג
שנים כנסים בו ממש מבחינת מוחים טים דבות
חושים דני מבחינת שמות דק
>> למעלה נכון נמצא כמה שאמרנו מצרים מיומים
מתגלים 10ה דמים אלו הם מבחינת בושים בסמן
הגדלות אז איפה אנחנו נמצאים בספירת העומר
ובפסח איפה כן גדולות לא בקדות אף פעם כי
בזה היה קטנות זה על הפנים
אוקיי, סגור הגענו לדרוש דף פא דרוש ג אז
בוא נקרא מה כתוב כאן שהמצב של הזה בפסח
בגלל מצרים על הפנים סתכלו קטנות
מצרים הפסח באותו ב שבנית מצרים חיצוניים
נכזים בת הקדושה
>> בנם חיצוניים הכי קשה לכן חזר זה
>> חזר זה למדרגה יותר גבוהה שהוא יותר
מבחינת ג
ולכן עלה ברצון המאזיל העליון להוציא את ז
בסוד לדם אם יאמו ולהגלילו בתכלית הגדלות
שאפשר להיות לו
>> ברור אז הוא הכניס אותו הקדוש ברוך הוא
התעשה לגדלות למה כדי לבטל לחזר את
החיצונים אבל
>> לאותיו שלתה ולא הספיק גם מה שהתגד לכות
הראשון בבד אשר הוא בחינת שאר ימים טובים
כמובן להם עניין טוב שאין עליה זון
אז רק ביני דתבונה לבד כ
>> וכולי רואים את זה אז מה המצב קנה שהמצב
הכי שפל שלך זה הקליפה זה אלוהים קטנות
רואים קטנות
זה רע כי זה אחיזה דקה לי מה עשה הקדוש
ברוך הוא העלה אותי למדרגה שגדלות ויצאנו
ממצרים מה קרה אחרי ליל הסדר את פחודה ואח
רואים אפשר ללמוד זוהר בכמה צורות זה אחד
הפירושים של הזוהר סתכלו וגם בזה תביא
>> גם תביא גם בזה תביא מה שכתוב בספר הזוהר
פרשת אמור א עמוד ג רואים בוא נקרא זוהר
תראו איך כותבים זוהר
>> גם תביא גם בזה תביא מה שכתוב בספר הזוהר
פרשת אמור כעניין ימי ספירת העומר הם בסות
ספירת ז ימי נקיים
>> שבעה ימי נקיים אוקיי ברור לכם מה הפשטה
זה ספירת אתה אומר אנחנו טמעים לנפש אדם
ואנחנו סוברים כמו אישה נידה אז מה זה
ספירת אומר על הפנים לא רואים כתוב לא
כתוב רואים שזה על הפנים למה כי זה ספירת
כי נמשיך הלאה
כדי שתה רשע עליונה לבעלה בחג השבועות
וכאובה כיוון שהיה ייחוד עליון בליל פסח
כמו שזכרנו זכרנו בשם ספר הזוהר פרשת אמור
אם כן הרי יצאת מחילת הטומ של גלות מצרים
והיא נתרה לבעלה ונתייחדה עמו ואיך חוזרת
אחר הייחוד ההוא לספור ימניקים אבל העניין
יובן אם אני אזכר כי הנה עניין הטומ הזאת
היא נמשכת מאותם ה דמים של טומאה שקיבלה
בזמן גלות מצרים מבחינת לבוש הגבורות מר
מה היא קיבלה חמש גבות מה היה גלות מצרים
חמש גבורות לנקבה אז בגלל שהיו חמש גבורות
לנקבה וזה נקרא מוכרים לקטנות אז היה כל
הגלות של מצרים אז מה הסנה של גלות מצרים
תגידו
>> תיקחו
עד עמוד ב עט עמוד ג פ עמוד א פ עמודה ב ג
פ
זה לא תירוץ אחד לא
>> כן
>> רואים זה כמה תירוצים לא אתם רואים שיש
כמה הבדלים אתם רואים את ההבדלים בוא
נחזור עוד פעם בעט מה הסיבה
ג כלל בג זה נקרא קטנות זוכרים עט עמודה ג
ב
>> זה קטנות נכון ג כל קל מג וזה נגרם על ידי
למה שפרעה שהוא קליפה שולט על הגאון נכון
תפכו דף עד עמוד ב איפה זה נקרא קטנות
עיבור והיאניקה איפה זה גלות מצרים בגדלות
שכחנו מה שאמרנו לפי דקה
זוכרים שמה שכחנו מה שאמרנו לפי דקה
>> כי אמרנו כדור זה הכי גרוע איפה של המצרים
בגדלות אז איפה אחיזת מצרים בגדלות אוקיי
>> בוא נעבור לפ עמודה ב פה אצלנו פ עמודה ב
נכון פה
עמודה ב' מה יש לנו? גלות מצרים רואים אז
יש לנו גם דמים וגם זה חזר לעיבוד הפכו דף
מה אומר הרב בעמודה ג' אומר שכל מצרים היה
בגדלות זוכרים אז איפה זה מה זה אם היינו
בקטנות היה גרוע ביותר שבעולם בסדר אז
איפה זה כל כל פסח בגדלות לא בקטנות שכחנו
מה שאמרנו לפני דקה לפי דקה אמרנו קטנות
אחרי הדקה לי אז נחזור עוד פעם אז מה אומר
הרב לא מדובר על הקטנות אלא על הגדלות אז
אז כל מה ששבנו במצרים זה בגלל גדות דזה
רואים אקה ואז אם היה חלילה חס הסיבה בגלל
מוכים לקטנות היינו אנחנו בנינו בני בנינו
עדיין משעבדים לפרע במצרים אז זה גדלות
רואים רואים איך שהרב הופך את הסדר
>> רואים רואים את זה בוא נתקדם עכשיו אחרי פ
עמודה ג נכון רואים הגענו לפ עמודה ג זה
דרוש ב' רואים
סגור עכשיו הגענו לדרוש ג
דרוש ג רואים פא עמוד א' זה המקור השני מה
מה זה נקרא אומר במי פסח עזר הוא נמצא
במצב הכי ש ג כלל מג במוחין לקטנות אחיזת
הקלי סגור שכחנו גדלות מקודם נכון מקודם
אמרנו גדלות
>> שכחנו את זה עכשיו שכחנו את זה רואים נכון
>> מסכימים הכי קל ללמוד שרקבות למה כי אתה
יוצא סתום הלאה
>> אה
>> שלוש שתיים בינתיים
>> כן אז נחזור פעם אז מה כתוב בדרושג ג כתוב
שהמצב הוא הכי שפל שיש בעולם ובגלל שהוא
הכי שפל אז עזרה חזרה לקטנות אוקיי כדי
להיגאל מה צריכים לעשות להביא מוכים
וגדלות אז הוא יוצא מג כלל מג והוא מתגדל
נכון אבל אחרי ליל הסדר הוא חוזר למצב קשה
עכשיו יש לנו זוהר סף חוד
הוא עם זוהר שזוהר אומר שבגלות מצרים היה
מצב שפל בגלל על חמש גבורות שניתנים בנקבה
נכון חמש גבורות זה לא בגלל הזה זה בגלל
נוגרה בגלל אשתו
האישה שנת עם ידי איפה זה עכשיו איפה זה
התחלנו בזה עברנו לנו כבר רואים אז כדי
לתרץ זה מנג שזה זוהר נכון אם אתה רוצה
לפתור איזה בעיה כתוב בזוהר אף אחד לא
ידבר איתך איתך פתרת את כל הבעיות שיש
בעולם אוקיי אף אחד לא יתווכח איתך זוהר
גמרנו עושבי הלאה מי תוכח מה נתקר אז
לחזור פרשת יומה מה כתוב שמה? שספירת עומר
זה ימי ספירת ניקים. שבעה ניקים.
ומאיפה זה בא? זה בא מהגבורות, חמש גבורות
שניתנו בגלות מצרים לנו כבר. אז איך היה
האיחוד בליל הסדר? אז אומר, אתה צודק, זה
היה לא על ידינו. זה היה כמו מקווה לטהר
אותנו. אבל אחר כך, אחרי ליל הסדר, הכל
מסתלק וחוזרים לספור לאט לאט. אז מה זה
ספירתו? אומר לטהר את האדם מטומעת הגבורות
קטנות שיש בנו כבר. סגור. בוא הגענו עכשיו
לדרושחי.
אוכלים שלוש מצות. זוכרים?
>> כן.
>> אז מה אמרנו? מה זה שלוש מצות? אמרנו שזה
אלוהים. אז מה כתבו בהתחלה ג? רואים אות
ג' זה מזולתויות. זה לא יכול להיות שזה
אמר הארי.
למה זה לא יכול להיות? כי אמרת שגלות
מצרים זה גדלות. לא אוכלים מצאות. גדלות.
איך הגעת עכשיו לקטנות?
רואים אז מה כותב הרב פה? רואים סתכלו
אומר אוכלים מצה ראשונה די
>> אם זה לא דו
>> מצע שנייה דו נכון
>> כן
>> עושים אפיק שילמנו כסף על זה הלאה
נכון וד דלה וענייה והו נשארנו אותו
לכוירך נכון והחלק האחרון נשארנו אותו
לקורך השלישי ששארנו אותו לקורך ואז
יכולים הפיקן בסוף ואז יש מחלוקת בפוסקים
מה זה נקרא עיקר המצע מוציא לך מן הארץ על
חלץ מצה הוא הפיקומה נכון אם יש לאדם רק
כזה ז יאכל אותו יאכל אותו בעמוסי לחמר
רצה לכל או באפיק קומה נכון מה כתבו
הפוסקים באפיקומה
>> אוקיי סגור מסכימים
>> פיקומה
>> ברור נכון זה מה שכתוב הפוסקים נכון ככה
כתבו הפוסקים
אז בוא נקרא אנחנו בחלק השני אז זה אומר
דידור חי אז עכשיו מחדש חידוש אומר כל יום
ספירת העומר נחזור פסח זה מצב הכי שפל נהי
רואים נהי אמרנו לפני דקה שהמצב הכי אאלי
זה פסח פה כתוב שפסח זה נקרא אלוהים
דיהודין הינרפין המצב הוא על הפנים לכן
אוכלים דיקטיב שלוש מצות תוך שתי דקות ואם
לא נחנקים הלאה מתקדמים הלאה בסדר זה זה
מה שק רואים פה זה עושה מה זה סבירת העומר
זה מצב יותר אידיאלי חגה סגור רואים מה זה
חג השבועות חבל הבנו מה שכתוב כאן אז הם
כתבו מזולתו אף אחד רואים פה מזולתו זה
ברור שזה מזולתו לא יכול להיות שזה
אוקיי זה מה שקושיה שמצאו פור דף רואים
כתוב כאן שהמצב של מוכים בקטנות הוא על
הפנים
לכן עושים כל מיני מעשים כדי לגול את
הקטנות איך עושים את זה אומר מכניסים
אורכים באמא על ידי היין אחר כך אוכלים
קרפס למה כי הקטנות של תבונה שר נטהר ברור
זה כתוב אצלכם בדף פ עמוד הג רואים
נעבור עכשיו בלי להיכנס לכוסות הקדם עםגל
הגענו לפג אומרים פג אומר הרע מה אוכלים
אחר כך בעמודה ב רואים אחר כך עושים
אומרים אוכלים מצא מוציא לכם מן הארץ זה
חוכמה גדלות דאבא את מי מטהרים את הקטנות
של ישס נכון לכן אוכלים דידור חי נכון
זוכרים דידור חי זה מה שכתוב כאן שהחי הזה
אוכלים את המצ וזה מכוח כוח האבא רואים פה
למה? כי עכשיו הקטנות ישס נטהרה אוכלים
אותה רואים תפכו דף רואים תפכו דף או הר
הלחמה ענייה זה תלמדו בבית אוקיי עכשיו יש
מוסר דרוש ז מוסר מזולתו ש שאדם הוא בגיל
צעיר יש לו מוחין רואים נק
>> רואים זה דרשה לבר מצווה כן
>> רואים
אז כל הימים שהוא קטן הוא לא חוט
שמגיע לבר מצווה אז נכנס בו יצר הטוב ויצר
הרע מוכין בקטנות לכן מתחילים לדון אותו
בר מצווה מה קיבלת מתנה בוקש עלה
נכון מה שכתוב כן רואים
ברור אוקיי אז לכן אומר הרב שזה נקרא
הגבורות שמתפשים מספירת העומר כמו ילד
בגיל ברבי יצא שמתחיל להכנס היצר הרע זה
דרשות הגענו לדרוש חורים דרוש חכ
>> דרוש חת חוסר אותה אומר בפסח היה לנו גדלו
הזן ניצל אחרי שישקו המוכין חוזרים לסמו
ספירת העומק כדי לטאר אותו מחבד חגעת
מלכות שהם היו אחוזים בקי אוקיי הגענו לפד
עמוד הב רואים לכן עושים הבחה גדוז גדלות
דיסות קטנות בסוף מכניסים קטנויות רואים
פה זה מה ש אומר הרב למטה רואים מצא את
ההבדלים למטה יש מצא את ההבדלים הפחנו דף
הפחנו דף
רואים דמים דמים האלה זה פד עמודה גד שמה
זה כדור ברית מילה שמתפשטים מהחסדים בורות
א שהיינו במצרים היינו החולים על ידי
אלוהים קטנות ושיצאנו בקראת קמסו נכנסו
בוכים לגדלות רואים אוקיי הגענו ל
דף פ ה עמוד ג רואים פ עמודה ג
אז מספר הרב סיפור על קורבן העומר קורבן
העומר היום לא מקריבים אז מי זמן שהיה בית
המדרש קיים דקרבת קורבן העומר הרמפים
החסדים הגבורות מיסודי אמא בגרון נזה
ומשמה לידי ספירת העומד פשטים כל החסדים
הגבורות בגוף של הזה נכון אבל היום אומר
הרב אין קורבן העומר אז מה הפסדנו שהחסדים
והגבורות שאמורים להתפשט בתוך הגוף הדיזה
לא מתפשטים לכן איך קוראים לימים האלה ימי
קטנות למה כי הקליחזים בתוך הגוף של הזהב
ואין לנו אפשרות לבטל אותם לכן מה אומרים
הרחמן
הרחמן מחזיר לנו עבודה בית המקדש למקומה
במרה בימין למה אומרים את זה כי ידי הרחמן
מכונים אור המקי שאור המקי בגלל שיש לנו
זכר למקדש אין לנו קורבן העומר אז שאומרים
הרחמים על המקיף ובגלל שהמקיף נמשך אולי
גם הפנימיים אשר סגור אומרים אז בן תת
ימים זה אולי
אולי אולי נמשכו מה הגענו לחג השבועות
אומר בחג השבועות יש איחוד
והאיחוד הזה מה הוא נקרא? אייחוד לגדלות.
למה? כי נמשכים גם החסדים מעזה לנוקווה.
זאת אומרת אם נגיד שנמשכו החסדים הגבורות
בתוך חזה אז עכשיו הוא מעביר את החסדים
בחג השבות לנוקבה ואז זה נקרא מוכים
בגדלות. עד כאן ברור? רואים את זה? הגענו
לפרק פו עמודה ב למטה. רואים אומר הארי
שנתעסק במה שיצעק אליי. זה נקרא אלוהים
דקטנות אסור להתעסק בו נכון שורה האחרונה
העניין כינדע כי אין החיצוניים נחזיר אלא
במוכים לקטנות נכון לכן הם מספירת אומר
מים מאבילות למה הם ממבלות כי זה מוכים
לקטנות לא קונים גדים חדשים לא ברכים
שחיינו
יותר גרוע מצב זה רואים כמעט זה העיבוב של
המושגים
לנמם זה אתה לוקח מושגים אתה מערבב אותם
יצא לך פיצוץ אתה משלב בזה גם לפי הקבלה
הלכה לא ללכת לברכה בימים האלה וכול מה
שכתוב כאן רואים כי זה דינים זה קטנות
רואים כתוב הלאה נינים
אוקיי אמרים שיהיה הפסקת יש כ זה מלחמה לא
טוב לנו הלאה פסח חשבנו חשבנו ולא קרה שום
דבר אוקיי נגיד סגרו רואים פה אז זה מה
שכותב כאן משה רבנו היה מתעשה בשנה במוכים
לקדנות
והוא ראה שהחיצונים נסגרים בו ברע
למה מה? כי על ידי עיסוק במוחים לקטנות אז
הם רוצים להתאחז בהם ולא נאחזים מוכים
לקטנות. עד עכשיו למדנו שהם נחזים לקטנות.
עכשיו אנחנו קוראים שאין להם בכלל גישה.
מי מאפשר להם גישה למוכת? זה החטאים של
האדם. מה שמשה מתעסק במוכים לקטנות אז באו
הציאו לו את כל החטאים שלו. ועל ידי
החטאים שלו הם ניסו להיכנס למוכת קטנות.
לכן ברח. ברח. אוקיי. קראו בעמודה ג למטה
קורבן העומר בוא נחזור קורבן העומר קורבן
העומר אומר הרב זה בכלל לא שייך לזה שייך
לנוקווה
בסדר מה זה זכר למקדש מה זה זכר למקדש זה
פירוש אחר מה זה זכר למקדש זכר למקדש
הכוונה הזכר
הוא לא קיים יבם
זכרם ראשון זכרות זכר למקדש מה זה מקדש
מקדש זה הנקבה היסוד של הנקבה בגלל שהזכר
הוא במוחים בקטנות אז הוא לא מתאחד עם
הנקבה אז מה זה קורבן העומר? קורבן העומר
זה להעיר לנקבה חמש גבורות. אוקיי?
ושמארים חמש גבורות זה מה שעשה משה רבנו.
לכן נקרא משה רבנו אל שדי. רואים שדי שזה
פעמיים יוצא לנו משה נחש. רואים פה זה
החשבון שהוסיף פה שדי מכוונים וכולי
וכולי. אז מה עושים בעצם? לוקחים את
המוכים בקטנות. למרות שהם מוכים בקטנות
אנחנו מה עושים? משתמשים בהם. למה? עושים
משהו לא יהודי. זה לא נקרא מעשה יהודי.
למה? כי בפסח היה ייחוד עזבנו כבר היא
מעוברת.
אחרי שהיא מעוברת מה קרה לה? היא נשתה
אחות קטנה. ירדה למטה סרקו כל המוכים אז
היא חזרה להיות קטנה נקודה ואז גם הוא כתב
עכשיו היא רוצה ללכת היא לא יכולה ללכת.
למה? כרחם שלה צר נכון ויש בה נשמות
גדולות. מה רוצים מהקליפה
לפתח? חזרק מחכים ללידה. למה? כי ברגע בא
ליד שיצאו הנשמות האלה שלטו בהם איזה
נשמות של פסח מה איך נקראם הנשמות של פסח
גדלות או קטנות
>> גדלות לא החליטו פה אב
לא כתוב גדלות
>> כן אבל לא החליטו מה הםכן
>> עכשיו בשביעי של פסח יש מצווה להתייחד עם
האישה למה כדי להעביר את הייחוד שלנו
לקליפה ואז יוצאים הנשמות בסדר זה לא
יהודי זה לא רעיון יהודי בטוח
זה לא רעיון יהודי הלה זה רעיון גוי
אז זה כתב מה אנחנו פה
הבנתם? אז מה זה בעצם קורבן העומר? כמו
שכולם אומרים מעשה בהמה
זה מפה זה יצא לה מעשה בהמה מסכנים מעשה
בהמה אז בגלל שכתוב את זה כאן אז קורבן
אומר זה מעשה בהמה וזה נעשה מסעורים ומה
דרכה של בהמה אישה סותטה כל הדרשות יצאו
מפה מהדרשה הזאת אוקיי סגור זה מה שכתוב
כאן
>> מאכל בהמה ס
>> כן נכון מסכימים עשה מעשה בהמה לכן תביא
שעה וכן על דרך זה אוקיי הגענו תלמידי רבי
עקיב
היו בימים שלמי הקטנות
בגלל שהם היו ממוכים לכדור לא היינו
נוהגים כבוד זה לזה פז נכון ולכן מתו
בימים האלה לפני כן כתוב שכל מט ימים כולל
שבת כולל פסח הם ימי קטנות כל המט ימים
האלה הם ימי קטנות אין בכלל גדלות בימים
האלה אוקיי אז אני אשאל עכשיו מה זה ספירת
העומר כתנות גדלות קליפה קדושה טהרה פירוק
הדינים פירוק הקליפה
או הכל על הפנים. מה אתם אומרים? תראו
באיזה דף. א בוא נראה לכם מה עושים כולם.
בסדר יש שני מפלגות. שתי מפלגות בוא
נכתוב. אוקיי כתוב. מפלגת המאחור
של מפלגת המאכור. לקח את כל הימים של פסח
ספירת העומר.
לקח את כל הימים פסח, ספירת העומר לאחיזת
הקליפה.
>> דינים קשים.
>> בסדר?
וכל הימים האלה צריכים להיזהר
צריכים להיזהר
הקליפה כי זה מוכין לקטנות
ואנו
רואים זה המפלגה הראשונה
יש מפלגה שנייה זה גם המאחור מפלגה שנייה
טוב זה
>> המצב התחלתי
>> זה תקופות שונות של
>> הוא רע לא זה אותו דרשה מסב התחלתי גורה
על ידי ספירת העומר הופכים אותו לטוב כי
הוא נטהר הוא נטהר
לא שזה היה מהתחלה טוב לא היה מהתחלה רע
אוקיי זה מפלגה השנייה עד כאן ברור לכם
עד כאן ברור לכם
מפה נכנס הרשש
בסדר מפה נכנס הרשש הרשש נכנס אבל הוא
עושה את זה בצורה מאוד מתוחכמת רואים שהוא
עושה את זה בצורה מאוד מתוחכמת א' הוא לא
מעתיק את כל הדרשות
רואים שהוא מעתיק שהוא רוצה לדבר על מוכים
לקטנות זה לא כתוב בכל הנהר שלום נכון
שכתוב בכל מיני מקומות כתוב בדף לג כתוב
בדף ל כתוב ל כתוב אף אחד לא חולקז לו
כתוב אף אחד לא חולק אבל יש לו נקודה שהוא
הולך לעבוד עליה מאוד חזק ואז זה הוא קורא
לזה מורכים בכטות אוקיי אז בוא נקרא
תסתכלו איך הוא עושה את זה בטח קור אוקיי
נקרא דף אנחנו קוראים לב
עמוד ב נכון אז בוא נכתוב כאן
דף נהר שלום לב
עמודה ב אוקיי אז בוא נקרא מה זה נקרא
להכניס עז בוא נכתוב רואים בהתחלה תזכו
בהתחלה בדף לב רואים בהתחלה כתוב נח רואים
נח
>> כן
>> רואים נח נח אז זה דף נח רואים נח
>> זה חן זה כן ולעלבים זה חן כן
>> אוקיי רואים תדגישו את זה תדגישו את זה
תדגישו מישהו את זה בוא נעבור לעמודה ב'
סתכלו כתוב שמה איזה דף כתוב
>> מה זה
>> עו נכון עו כן איך איך זה נח עו
>> דילוגים היה מלחמה זה לא עבד
>> איפה איפה זה עבר
>> אה
>> זה באמצע קטע איפה
>> איך זה עבר מנח לעוכן כן
>> לא עבדו היה מלחמה לא עבדו אז הוא לא הגיש
מס הכנסה כל הימים האלה הוא לא הגיש מסך
נסה לא הגיש שום דבר אוקיי
>> באמצע הקטע זה עובדה אה
>> באמצע הכרד
>> נכון הבנתם מה שעשו פה הבנתם מה שעשו כאן
תח רואים רואים פז בעמודה ג רואים פז
רואים פז אתם רואים את זה מה שכתוב כאן אה
>> אוקיי פז אמרנו עכשיו למטה למטה עמוד ד
רואים נט
יחידת נט הלה
>> זה המשך כן
>> אוקיי
למה עשו את זה
>> למה עשו את זה
>> אז בוא תכתוב תכתוב נהר שלום
>> עז מה? סיפורו של דף. נכתוב. סיפורו של
דף. אוקיי? סיפורו של דף. נכתוב. נכתוב.
אם מפרידים
את דפי נח
הישן
מדפי
עוז,
נכון?
מקבלים פירוש
מקבלים פירוש מקבלים פירוש
>> שהוא לא טועם שום דבר משמונה שערים
מנתם זה לא טועם שום דבר
שום דבר זה לא טועם
לא טועים כלום הבנתם כל מה שהצגנו מדף עט
עד הודעה חדשה זה לא טועם לא טועם אי אפשר
אי אפשר להסתדר עם זה לכן נכתוב לכן לכן
התלמידים
של הרשש
ארכו מחדש את נהר שלום רחבות הנהר אכו את
זה מחדש חו זה מחדש נכון וכדי להגן על
הרשש
כדי להגן על הרשש
נכון חיברו חיברו דף נח
עפו כאילו זה נושא אחד הבנתם
הבנתם מה שכתוב כאן חיבו זה כאילו זה נושא
אחד בוא נראה מה זה הנושא אחד בוא נכתוב
מה הנושא למה זה נושא אחד
אוקיי
>> דף נט עם עם עו
>> עם עו עז עז עם עזברו את העז הזה
>> רואים בוא נקרא למה נכתוב נכתוב כי בשאר
הכוונות בשאר הכוונות למדנו שכל ספירת
העומר זה תוצאה של פגם של אדם הראשון
פגם של אדם הראשון
והימים האלה הם קטנות דינים קליפה
קליפה נכון
והימים האלה חסרים עוצמה רוחנית
חסרים עוצמה רוחנית והרשע שהגיעה למסקנות
הרשע שהגיעה למסקנות מאחיקות לחם בגלל
המצב הזה נכון שלא מכוונים לא בתפילות לא
במצוות לא בלימוד תורה כלום אין שום
כוונות
ברור
למרות זאת, למרות זאת, למרות המצב הנעל,
למרות המצב הנעל, כותב הרב הלכות, הלכות
בוא תראו איזה הלכות לא הגיוניות, נכון?
בוא נכתוב נכתוב כל ימי חולם רועב
לא אומרים לא תיקון רחם ולא תיקון לא למה
לא אומרים תיקון לא?
לא אומרים.
בסדר?
אוקיי? לא אומרים תיקון שאומרים שכן
>> מי אומר שאומר כן מי אומר ככה יודע בסדר ש
>> אה בן איש חי הוא בן איש חי יכול להיות
>> אוקיי ברור משה
>> מסכימים או לא אמרתם או לא אמרתם
>> אני לא אמרתי
>> אמרתם או לא אמרתם
אבל אה
>> נכון בוא נביא אמת ליעקב תביא אמת ליעקב
תביא אמת ליעקב
אמת ליעקב בוא נקרא אמת ליעקב הנה רואים
אמת ליעקב הנה קב ב עמודה
הנה אמר המעתיק קרא אמר המעתיק למטה אמר
המעתיק הועיל ואתה ליד קב עמודה ד אמר
המעתיק הועיל ואתה לידוע ואתה לידן עניין
הכוונות ראיתי לכתוב כאן הימים שאין אנו
מכוונים בשם
>> בהם
>> בהם בקהל בקהל חסידים ב לא מכבלים בבית
>> כן על פי הורת מורנו הרב
>> לא על פי הרשש הרשש אמר את זה מה אמר
ספירת העומר זה על הפנים אסור להגיד גוד
רחל למה מה אתה אומר זה על הפנים קליפה לא
איזה איזה היגיון יש לך אה קראו צה
לאחר בית ימים שלוש שנה עד שמיני עצרת אין
לך מן קבלת התפילה זולת קבלת הנסירה
>> וכולי
>> וכולי ויום הכיפורים מכבלים כל אחר הבונות
וייחודים פסח
>> שנקודה כוללת כל פרצוף שאין לכוון כאלה
ימים
>> גם כל העומר
>> גם בכל ימי העומר אין אנו מכוונים כוונת
התפילה לא מכים קבל תפילה ולא קבל חצלים
תיקון רחל
>> לא אומרים תיקון רחל
>> וגם בפסח לא אומרים תיקון לאה
>> ומסתלקים
>> מכוני למה כי יש אחי דקה ליה זה הפסיקו
אפילו לאה לא אומרים
>> גם הן אומרים תיקון לאה
>> לא אומרים תיקון לאה כדור ולא כדור
>> חול מוריד פסח
>> בסדר לא אומרים בכל פסח לא אומרים תיקון
לאה כתוב ולא כדור זה על פי הוראת הרשש
עדות נכון למטה אתה נכתוב אבל חלוקים עליו
חברה
>> חלוקים עליו חברה בעניין הזה נכון החברים
שלו חלוקים עליוגים
>> בסדר חלוקים עליו יש לך הרב הרב דלרז מי
לנו גדול מהרב אנחנו מתבטלים זה עכשיו
עליו
>> חברים שלו
>> אה
>> הרב דילו זה
>> נכון אז הם חלוקים עליו אומרים שמה שהוא
אומר שזה לא נכון
>> חכם
>> הבנתם אומרים שזה לא נכון אז לכן מה הם
עשו בוא נחזור פעם לכן הם כתבו לכן חיברו
>> נחזור אם לכן חיברו את דף
נח שכתוב בו כל הדברים הרעים שכתובים
למעלה נכון
כדי שנקרא את דף
עוז
עם ההשראה
של חגדמזו הבנתם מה עשו כאן
נכון
הבנתם מי זה הבת ליעקב הרב ליניו קבור שנה
שלוש שורות מעל הרשש כל הזמן לצערי הרב
ואנחנו דורכים עליו
נעשה כדי להגיע לראשש דורכים אין שמה מקום
מחילה
>> כל מחילה ממנו מה נעשה זה הרב ניניו, בסדר
זה הרב ניניו הוא כתב ספר אמת ליעקב רואים
זה הוא כתב פירושים
וכולי וכולי זה הוא כתב כל מה שהיה פה
בישיבה הנה רואים פה הוא זה מביא הרבה
דברים
אמת ליעקב נכון זה הרב ניוור עליו השלום
אוקיי סגור זה הרב ניניור אוקיי אז עכשיו
אנחנו חוזרים לנושא בגלל שזה הדבר הזה היה
קשה וגם לתלמידים של הרשב זה היה קשה איך
אומר הרב ב אנחנו לא נקרא עוד דקה איך
אומר הרב בדף עוז
לא מתייחס בכלל לא לאדם הראשון לא לקליפה
לא לשום דבר ואדרבה לפי דבריו יוצא נכתוב
נכתוב בדפי פו בדפי עו עז שקוראים רואים
שבכלל הרשש מעצים את הימים האלה איך זה
יכול להיות לכן חיברו את שני הדפים הבנים
חיברו את שני דפים ויצא לך כמו פשט שר
הכוונות ברור הבנתם מה שעשו פה
מסכימים זה מה שעשו זה מה שעשו פה
זה מה שעשו פה אוקיי אז אנחנו עכשיו
קוראים הרשש בדף לב עמודה ב רואים
רואים איפה שכתוב נט
איפה שכתוב עצ לב עמודה ב למטה שכתוב פו
רואים שאלה
עט שאלה נכון שאלה
גדשתי
ש כן לא עמוד הב אתה קורא עמוד הב אנחנו
קוראים פו פו לא עט בנט
>> עו
>> אוקיי עו אנחנו קוראים בוא נקרא שאלה אם
יש לך בתפילות ובמצוות ובעליות שבת
ובייחודים בימי העומר כשר ימות השנה או אם
יש שינוי למה למה שתהיה שאלה למה שתהיה
שאלה למה שיש
בחנוכה הים מכוונים בחנוכה או זה למה אין
שאלה פסח מכוונים בפורים מכוונים לא בראש
השנה מכוונים תגיד שאלה אותו שאלה מה
נתקעת בפסח שאסור לי אוקיי האם מכוונים
בתפילות ובמצוות נכון אז כל אחד יגיד איך
כל דבר דביקות דקות בהשם יתברך דבקות ואיך
אדם מתלל בלי כוונות אין דבקות אין בסדר
כמו שאני אומר הכוונות שתה מדבר כוון לא
על זה דיבר שתה יכול להמשיך לחבין את זה
הלאה לא על זה דיבר הרב הלאה בסדר
אוקיי
היינו פעם במרון לא משנה לפני לפני שנה
שנתיים לא הכניסו נכון בגלל הפעמיים אחד
קורונה ואחד בגלל ההפגזה מהצפות
>> אוקיי אם יהיה פעם שלישית זה יבנה הבית
הלאה
זהו שלוש פעמים זה גמרנו
>> אוקיי אז היה הסדר מן חכם הוא כל הזמן
משגע אותי כל הזמן משגע אותי מוציא אותי
מדעתי על אבל אני אף אחד לא עונה לו עכשיו
אני ישב לידי אמר לי שהכוונות באים לו ב
ככה
בזה אז הוא אומר איך שהוא מגיע לרשבי 17
דקות הוא מכוון אמרתי לו בסדר תכבה אני
יוצא לך וזה מהזה אני שאני תליה לו את
אמרתי לא לך אתר זה כתוב בהרש זה אוקיי אז
זה אחד מהצרים הרעים שלי זה מספר לכם אותם
אז אמרתי אני אני אעמוד אחריו שאנחנו
נמצאים שמה למעלה אני אקרא את זה הזוהר
תגיד רשיניים ואני אראה מה איך הוא מתנהג
אוקיי ראיתי שהיינו שם בשלוש אני רואה
אותו כל זמן שער רוקד עם כולם עולה מהסור
וזה חכה מתי אני מכוון מתי הוא מכוון
ראיתי כבר השעה 4 אומר תישנת
צריכים לחזור הלכתי עלי לבד לרשבי הכניסו
אותי בפנים אמרוק יש לך 10 דקות הכנסתי
בפנים קראתי תהילים קראתי קטורת קראתי זה
חזרתי בחזרה למה אני יותר רוקדים את זה
ובחזור הוא ישב לידי אמר לי אמרתי לו איך
היו הכוונות זה אומר או שכחתי
זה בא לוטומט לא בסדר על מי אתה עובד עליו
שכחתי על מי אתה עובד עליו מה זה בא לך
אוטומט בסדר אוטומט זה בא לו אוטומט
לא הבנת את הקטע שלו, לא הבדיתי להביא מה
אתה עושה תחבודה אוקיי אז בוא נחזור אז
שואל הרשש נכתב שואל הרשש נכתוב שואל הרשש
בכל יום אנחנו מכוונים להפריד את הקליפה
ואין לנו בעיה
נכון
בספירת העומר ובפסח
נכון יש לנו בעיה
סגור אז בוא תראו איך הוא בונה את הראש.
תראו איך הוא בונה את הראש. גם הוא עשה
אינדוס. סתכלו לב. איפה הוא אומר לקרוא?
תסתכלו איך הוא אומר לקרוא. אומר לקרוא
דרוש ג אבל בעמוד הג'. רואים? שמתם לב?
תגו איך הוא עושה לב עמודה ב' למטה? בוא
נקרא שאלה, נכון? שאלה.
>> שאלה.
>> האם יש לכוון או אין לכוון? נכון? למה שיש
שאלה? אז לא מכבלים בתפילות או בקיום
המצוות או בייחודים. אוקיי? סגור. כתוב לא
מחים בייחודים.
מסכימים? אוקיי, נמשיך הלאה.
מי שהכניס לו לכוון בעולם היום, מהעולם
הקבלי זה הרב גתחלה כולם היו חמים. כולם
היו חמים, כל היו, כל התפילה, הכל, הכל
מחמים, הכל. מי שהכניס את זה זה הרב ג זה
ה מלחמות יהודים, אבל לאט לאט הם השתנו
לאט לאט. נכון? וגם בייחודים על כבר
צדיקים לא השתנו. יש יום אחד בשנה שכולם
הולכים לשבוע הנביא ומכוונים ייחודים חות
חותם חיברתי כולם. ככה הולכים כולם שמואל
הנביא. למה? כי מרגישים שקרה משהו בעולם.
אז מה יעשו? יגידו וידוי, יעשו את החנון.
אי אפשר להגיד את החנון. יגידו הלל זה
יתפסו אותך.
אה ברור. אז מה עושים? הולכים כולם לשמולי
הנביא רוקדים שמחים. למה זה היום נפטר
שבולי הנביא? אז אין את החנון עלה.
>> כן. בראשי כתוב מתי נפטר? בראש השנה יום
ב'.
בסדר. דקמינה לנו החלידו שזה שמעל הנביא
זה כח. בסדר. חדו נגד חלבילה אבחד לא נגד
אוקיי סגור אז עושים ייחודיים כמו הבן איש
חי עליו השלום שצניו בן ידי ה חו ייחודים
נכון והוא כותב הבן איש חי כותב שאיך
נעשים הייחודים בימים של חודש ניסן
חודש ניסן יחודים איזה לפני פסח או אחרי
פסח
מה ש מסביר עליו
>> שני פסח פשיטה אבל א
>> אה הבנים או לא הבנתי מדבר היפה מדבר
איתכם עליו
אוקיי סגור אז נחזור אז אז אומר הרש נקרא
אומר לקרוא את החילול חילובה
הנה התשובה קרה
>> לכאורה נראה שנכבן כלל בשום
>> שכבן כלל שום כוונה המשכחת המוכין שבסדר
העומר וטו
>> למה פני פחד הקלי שלא יתאחזו כנודר
>> נכון בגלל שתחבן הכל התאחזו לא שיתאחזו
אלא לא מעיפים אותם
>> שלא יתאחזו הבנת איך ההלכת יסוד שלו
>> לא שיש קליפה
אלא שלא יתאחזו אם אתה תכוון את את הקליפה
בקדושה הבנת סו איך איך הוא קורא גם
לאדמגם לא דקה לטראו איך הוא בונה את הזיר
הרב לא הבנתי את החלק ש
>> זה לא בגלל שיש אחיזה אלא אם תכוון אתחוז
את הקליפה בקדושה
>> אוקיי תקרא תקרא לאט לאט תקרא לאט לא
>> תחזור כן דע כמו שכתב האריזל כי אחר עבור
>> איפה זה כתוב
פתחו
>> פתחו דרוש ג אבל בעמודה ג' לא בהתחלה הוא
לא מעתיק את ההתחלה
רואים? תסתכלו פג פג עמוד א תסתכלו פג
עמוד א סתכלו
פג לא פשו
רואים אומר לא לקרוא את ההתחלה פא א'
סליחה פ א' פה פה
לא לקרוא את ההתחלה למה לא לקרוא את
ההתחלה
למה לא לקרוא עמוד הבקרוא עמוד הג בלי
זוהר
רואים מה זה בלי לקרוא זוהר בלי זוהר
רואים איפה אומר לקרוא שורה שמונית מלמעלה
רואים איך כתוב קיבלה חמישה דמים חמש
גבורות שבגלות מצרים כל זה מוחק מוחק מוחק
את זה נכון
רואים מוחק את זה מוחק את כל זה אז הוא
כותב שמה איפה מתחילים
רואים ככה
אבל אחר מדפס רואים רואים שמה כתוב איפה
זה שלא כדחטע רואים משמה הוא מעתיק
נכון למה הוא לא מעתיק את ההתחלה גם
צריכים לשאול למה הוא לא מעתיק אתה התחלה
>> לכה עבור יום א' של פסח נסתכל
>> שמה הוא מעתיק נכון שמת לב הוא מעתיק
>> אבל כתוב שחזיקו
>> לא אבל הוא מעתיק מאיפה מעתיק לא מלמעלה
למה למה הוא לא מעתיק מפא עמוד א' למה הוא
לא מעתיק משמה כתוב ש הכל אותו דבר אה
>> הוא אומר זה לא נכון למה לא נכון בוא נקרא
עוד אחד נקרא
קרע
>> ממשיך ב
>> בני שלום רואים תראו איך הוא מעתיק תראו
זה גם הלימוד זה לימוד איך הוא מעתיק הוא
מעתיק קודם כל פ עמודג ג ולא הכל עד איפה
שכתוב בחג השבועות הוא הייחוד רואים ככה
בור יום אד פסח נסתכלו מוכין חזרו
החיצונים תאחז אבל לא אחיזה גמורה לא
>> אחיזה גמורה כתחילה כי כבר נתבטלה אחיזתם
הגדולה וחזרו להתחרז בדמים ההם ואז נכנסים
המוכים כסדר המדרגות הוכפי סדר כניסתם כך
הוא סדר ביטול אחיזתם לאט לאט בהמשך ימי
ספרת העומר שהוא עניין שבעת ימי נקיים
>> נכון כמו שכתוב עם הנקיים נכון אבל לא
כתוב בזוהר נמשיך הלאה
>> ואז ניתומתו ונגמרת להטהר בחג השבועות ואז
חוזרת להתייחד עמו
על כן על כך עד כאן עד כאן אל תקרא יותר
לא למטה לא למעלה
>> עד כאן
>> יענו נגד הזוהר הלאה
>> שמתם לב אז זה מעי עכשיו בוא נקרא החלק
השני פדל רואים משמה הוא קופץ לפדל
רואים אתה קרא את אצלנו שאר כוונות שאר
כוונות פד נכון בוא נקרא הוא מעתיק את מי
כתוב רואים כתוב
אחר כך מל שאני ואלך אנחנו חוזרים להמשיך
בוא נקרא נהר שלום קראו נהר שלום ככה
>> ניר שלום
>> כן אחר כך מל שני ואלך אנחנו חוזרים
להמשיך המוכני נזכרים נכון הוא לא מעתיק
את ההתחלה
ג כלל מג מה שכתוב למעלה הוא לא מעתיק
נכון המצב של זל הפנים בפסח ממשיכים לא
מעתיק מתחיל פעם אחר לשני די פסח
>> חזרים להמשיך מוכזכר שנכנסו בפסח ונסתקו
עד ועתה חוזרים להיכנס
>> פי סדר המדרגה כל מדרגה ביום של ידי מצוות
ספירת העומר
>> נכון זה מה שמעתי
>> אוקיי מה בגלל דף הבא פו
פו איפה עד עמוד ב איפה עד עט עמוד ג איפה
פ עמוד א' עמודה ב איפה פא התחלה לא כתוב
מה שמעתיק אני חוזר פעם פ א' עמוד הג הוא
מעתיק פד ההתחלה בלבד הוא מעתיק את פו תחד
פו עינן כל המים תימים נכון זה מה שהוא
מעתיק ענן כל זה מה שהוא מעתיק קרש זהו
אין אין אין דפים אין מקומות אין מקומות
אחרים אין מקומות אחרים
מסכימים לעומת נט תראו שזה מקורות אחרים
בכלל נט נכון נחנט זה מקורות אחרים כמו
שעוד דקה אני אראה לכם עוד דקה נראה לכם
אז בוא נקרא אז מה עכשיו מתחיל להסביר הרב
אתיו אומרים אף אחד לא מתייחס לזה סתם ככה
כולם נגדו אף אחד לא מתייחס לזה אף אחד
בסדר
זה המשימה שלנו פה בישיבה
להוציא לכולם את הדם עלה דווקא לקחת את
כולם לבור לקחת את כולם הדרשה הזאת דווקא
זה הכי חשוב לדעתי אם מבינים את זה מבינים
את כל הקבלה לא מבינים את זה כן אומר מוכר
זה המשימה שלי סתם ככה גם של הרב גזו הלאה
זה המשימה שלנו להכניס את כולם לראש הנקי
הישר מבריק רואים קו יחד איתי
>> יאללה קוראים עוד דקה תסתכלו יחד איתי
תראו איך איך ה בונה את הראש לאט לאט נכון
זה שלוש מקורות שלרה נכון עכשיו פורדם
יאללה נקרא דרו שביעי של פסח כתב זה עניין
כל המט ימים שספירת אומר דע כי הייחוד אשר
באותם השבתות ביום ראש חודש אייר אשר אשר
>> אז איך אומר הרש לא לייחד כתוב בארי
פרשיחד לא אומר הרשש לא מיחד עם יחודים
בספרת כתוב פרשיחד לא אה
>> אשרות לנו יחוד
>> מה אתם
>> מדרסים
>> צריך להיות נשוי להבין את זה הלאה
>> כן כן
>> פשוט הלה
איפה כתוב יחודים של תפילה?
אוקיי,
מפה כתו יחודים של תפילה, נכון? אשרות טל
הייחוד בשבתות
הנה כתוב שמיחדים בשבתות
אוקיי? וכן זה כמו סיפרתי לכם הקורונה עשה
לי שריטה בראש שלי
לנו עם זה תלמיד חכם גדול מאוד הוא מכוון
הכל אמרתי לו מה מח כתוב רשע הביא לי את
זה לו תתחתן הלאה
כן היה לנו קורונה היה לנו מכה שלא כתובה
בתורה כל התפילות כוונו כי זה המניין
היחיד שהיו ספרים נתנו באידרה נכון
פלנו כל הזה בסוכה בחוץ הייתה סוכה שפקו
אותה
אין פלים ירד גש עם מבול כל פעם היה יורד
מבול עלה למה כי זה ייחוד הלאה
כל השבעלה
לא משנה אבל זה מילן החיישה לא יה מינני
מה נעשה בא נותן ערבים הלאה קורונה קורונה
יאללה נמשיך הלאה ק
>> על כל זה אין לנו איכות גמור של גדלות כי
עדיין זה בסוד הקטנות כ
>> סוד הקטנות כל ם תת ימים מסכימים אוקיי
נקרא עכשיו
בני איחוד ליל שביעי של פסח כל הייחודים
שבימים האלו הם על דרך על מה שכתוב ביחוד
ליל שביעי של פסח אלא שיש בהם שינוי קצת
כפי בחינת המדרגות מדרגת המכוין שנכנסו בו
בזמן ההוא כנל כי אינם נשלמים להיכנס כולם
עד חג השבועות ואז הוא איכות גמור דגדלות
כמו שנבראר
>> הלאה ברור בשבועות זה איכות דגדלות כתוב
פו
>> כתוב
>> עכשיו בוא נראה לכם מסביר הרב נחיל
>> הרי כיסיבת המשך זמן הכנסת המוחין במט
ימים ולא ביום אחד כישאר ימות השנה הוא
מפני רוב אחיזת החיצונים בו נכון כל מפני
שיש אחיזת החיצוני בוא בוא מי זה בו בוכין
או ב
>> מי בזה
>> שואל מי זה בזה או בו מה אתם אומרים בוא
נקרא
דה לבטל אותה אחיזה לגמרי הוא צרח במת
ימים כי מה שנתבטלה אותה אחיזה בליל פסח
לא היה אלא לפי שעה והיה על פי הנס ולא
היה ביטול לגמרי
>> כל כבס פסח אם שכנו מוכים היצה התבלו
החיצונים אבל לא ביטוי לגמרי אבל אחרי פסח
חזר הדבר לטבעו אבל אחר עבור יום א' חזר
הדבר לטבעו לבטל אחיזתם על ידי המשכת
המוכין כשאר יומות השנה ולא עלי שר ימות
השנה ממשיכים מוכין אז גם עכשיו בספירת
ממשיכים מוכין כמו שראמות השנה או כנראה
>> ועב לאט לאט לא בפעם אחת כישאר ימות השנה
כי עדיין אין בנו כוח לבטלה
>> למה אין בנו כוח
למה אין בנו כוח
למה אין בנו כוח? נכון? אז בוא נענה על
זה. בוא נעשה עיגול שחור.
אוקיי, נעשה עיגול שחור.
נעשה עיגול שחור.
נעשה עיגול שחור. קטן. כן. ובתחו נעשה
עיגול תכלת.
עיגול תכלת. אוקיי, רואים את זה? בוא נעשה
אותו דבר בצד הסברים. נעשה הפוך. עכשיו
נעשה עיגול שחור. בצד הסבר עוד רבע תעשה
עיגול. תעשה תכלת תתחיל תכלת תעשה עיגול
תכלת
תכלת ותעשה מולו עיגול שחור
>> כן תעשה עיגול שחור אוקיי איך קוראים
לציור השני יום חול כתוב למעלה יום חול
כתוב יום חול יום חול יום חול יום חול יום
רגיל יום חול יום חול
יום חול מה הם ההבדל בינינו לבין הטומא
הבנתם תסתכלו איפה אנחנו ביום חול בקדושה
רואים תכתוב בכחול קדושה
קדושה
איפה הטומאה
מחוץ לקדושה לא אצלנו הבנת
אוקיי אז למה אנחנו מסוגלים להתמודד עם
הטומאה כי אנחנו נמצא עם הקדושה הבנתם
אנחנו בקדושה והטומאה מולנו הפך קיבל את
העצמות
סגור מבינים?
מבינים מה שכתוב כאן? בוא נעשה מה קורה
בפסח? איפה הקדושה?
בפנים.
איפה הטומ? מסביב.
איפה הקדושה? בפנים. אז למה אין לנו כוח?
בגלל שאנחנו בשטח שלהם ואם אנחנו בשטח של
הטומאה. אז אומר הרב, אין לנו כוח.
לא בערב שבת. אילו היה לי כוח. לא בערב
שבת.
יש לנו קדושה יה לנו אין לנו שום בעיה
אוקיי
זה ההבדל לכן אין דוקח למה בגלל שאנחנו
נמצאים בתוך בתוך בתוך העסק הזה רואים
בפנים
>> מה ויש זמן קטנות זה בגלל זה
>> לא לא אל תגיד מה זה קטנות מה זה קטנות
>> לא מה שהרב מרחו אמר אני אסביר מה זה
קטנות לא אמר חמור לא שהרב שאנחנו בפסח
בתוך ה
>> בתוך הקליפה אנחנו מה אנחנו צריכים את
העיגול הכחול התחלת רואים את העיגול התחלת
>> אז לעזור מה צריכים לעשות עשות אותו לרומם
הבדל הקדושה
>> ביום רגיל איפה נמצאים בקדושה פטו במצב אז
שעושים מפני תקלי גדול יד ראש אין לנו
בעיה למה אין לנו בעיה מפרקים להם את
העצמות אנחנו בגזרה אחת הם בגזרה שנייה
אוקיי לעומת פסח איפה אחד נמצאים בפנים
רואים בפנים זאת אומרת העבודה השם שלנו
היא בפנים בתכלת
>> כל יום אחד
>> אוקיי אז אבל מה יש לנו יש לנו מסביב
רשעים כלי טיפה סגור אז אומר הרב כמה
פעמים יש לנו כאלה נכון רגע זה נכון רגע
זה 49 כאלה בחינות אוקיי סגור מסכמים בוא
נקרוא לאט לאט
האם החיצונים התחזו בתכלת לא נכון תגרו לא
נכון
>> נקרא בוא נקרא את תגיד ודאי שלא תקרא את
>> למה ודאי שלא תקרא בוא נקרא
>> א תקרא
אין לנו כוח לבטל אלא לאט לאט
>> במשךת ימים
>> הלאה
>> לאט לאט לא פעם אחת כשאר רושנה כי עדיין
הם בנו כוח לבטלה ופעם אחת
>> למה אין לנו כוח קח לנו בפנים
למה היום חודש לנו כוח קח לנו בחוץ כל
ההבדל כך כותב הארי דווקא כותב הרש דוקא
אומר מי שקם בחצות אז הוא בקדושה בגלל
שהוא בקדושה יכול לפרק את הטומ אבל מי חג
אליו חצו קם הוא בטומא לא יכול לפרק
כתוב כו לו בדף כ עמוד ב
>> ביום
>> תקראו תקרו כ
>> תקרו כ צריך להיזהר לם כולם בחצות קחו כ
עמוד ב
נכון ניר שלום כ עמוד ב
>> ני שלום
>> כ עמוד ב כן כלו זה מה שמרש
כ עמודה בוא
נקרא
זה אפילו קוראים את זה בתלמוד תורה מוריה
היינו בסיבת הורים בספירת העומר אמרו
להקדים את זה כי יש אנשים שלא טוב להם אז
הרב הרב של התלמוד הרב פתא דעו לכם ילדים
שכדב הרשש שימים אלה מסוגלים זה צריכים
למוד הרבה תורה כי זה שורש לכל השנה אם
אנחנו לומדים נכון הרב ישראל אמרתי לו מה
נגיד לך לך
נגמרה סיבת הורים הלכבית
יאללה נמשיך
>> בוא נקרא יש לכם כ עמוד ב נקרא
>> הוא זמנה
הילה אנחנו צריך להיזהר לאומרם כולם
מקומות
מהקוד קליל הלאה כדי להחזיר שהסתלקו קודם
חצות מהזה מזה הכולל דמידת היום ונתפשטו
בקוללת דמידת הלילה ועל ידה מגדלה כנגד כל
החורה הזו חצות ממש נמנסרת ובה לפנים
ומסתלקים ומוכים ממנה ועולים למן לאבא
ואמא ומתייחדים אבא ואמא וממשיכים מוכין
חדשים דפנים ומתחדשים גם מוכן הראשונים כי
נזכר כל זה באורך לקמן בברכת המעביר הן שם
ואתה לידברכות של השחר חוזרים ומוכים מהם
דאחור ופנים להתפשט בזה כולל דמ היום וכדי
להמשיך השפע
>> דמשיך אוכל לשפע לפרצופים העליונים לבטל
מהם אחיזת הקליפות שהם תאחזו בהם קודם
חצות כנודע ורדי לברי הבירורים המתייחסים
לכל ברכה וברכה ואם לא יאמר אותם כולם
בקומו בחצות מונע המשכת השפע והמוכין
לפרצופים העליונים וגורם להשאיר אחריזת
הקליפות במקומם במקומות עליונים או בנרנ
החי שלו החושים שלו ב אז מה ההבדל בין פסח
לבין יום רגיל יום רגיל אתה לא בתוך
הקליפה אתה מחוץ לקליפה אתה נלחם נגד
הקליפה שהיא בחוץ אין לך בעיה אבל בפסח
בוא נסתכל פה בפסח נחזור
>> הפוך
>> כאן כתוב שכאן אתחזו כאן
>> אה לא לפני לפני חצות
>> זה לפני חצות מי שלא קם חצות לפני חזים אז
הוא לא יכול
>> תחזו לפני חצות בחצות
>> לא באדם בקדושה
>> אבל לא בנו אנחנו טורואים
>> אוקיי ש נותנים ידיים אפשר לשתות ביזה קפה
רק נגעלים הלאה לא אין בעיה במים האלה
לזרוק אותם וזה אין לך בעיה לדם לזרוק
אותה בקיור לא קרה שום דבר הלאה כי זה לא
טומאה זה לא מים צמעים הלאה תמשיכו הלאה
כל כך הרבה שמות קיבלת עליהם אתה לא עלו
לשתות אותם הלאה ממשיך הלאה
>> אז עקר זה הירת בבת השחר
>> לא כמעט חצות שיש כמעט חצות אתה בך לכונה
אין כמעט חצות אין דרך לכונה זה מה שכתוב
כ אפשר לקבל אוי
לא לא האמירת הסיכור
>> ממנה אמירת עצמ ברור אתה לא קם כדורג השחר
>> בקוד השחר אתה אומר בקוד השחר אחד אחד
אחור פנים פנים מחזירים את המוחים מגלים
את לאם יחדים כל זה זה לא ש כדבר הרב הלאה
נחזור לנו שלנו עכשיו נחזור לפ ללב עמוד
הג רואים
לב עמוד ג
>> הלאה א זה משת השנה דיינו הקדמות בגדלות
שאילו נמשך הקדמנות תחילה היו מתאחזים
והוא חס ושלום ול
>> אז בקדמנות לא יש הקטנות הוא טהור או יש
בו אחיזה אומר לא הקטנות
אם אתה תכוון בו בהתחלה כמו כל השנה כולה
אז יתחזו החיצוניים אבל בגלל שרואים את
התחיל הזה נכון שהוא נמצא במקום מסובך אבל
אין בו אחיזה
אז מה אתה מטפל אתה מטפל בתחילת בלי
להתייחס בכלל לטומא רואים הבנת לאט לאט
בוא נקרא פה לא צט אומר ואם הם נשכים
כישרים עוד השנה כך
>> גם שאילו נמשך הקדנות תחילה היו מתאחזים
בו חס ושלום ולכן
>> חס ושלום החיצונים נכון היו מתחזים בו לכן
גם למשחת הבוכים היו כסדר וגם
>> זה לא כסדר אז מה אומר הרב שזה סדר אלוקי
שמי קבע אותו הקדוש ברוך הוא
>> אתה לא מצ
>> זה לא סדר הגיוני נכון איך זה קוראים לזה
הלכה למשה בן סיני מה זה הלכה למשה סיני
כל דבר שהוא בדיני טומא וטהרה זה הלכה
למשה בן סיני נכון רביעית מים רביעית
אכילה שזה זה דיני טומאה וטהרה אז זה הלכה
למשה בן סי סינה למה כי אנחנו לא מבינים
איך דרכי הטומאה לא מבינים דרכי הטומאה
לכן יש כל מיני הלכות
בסדר מסכימים זה מה שכתוב כאן הלכה למשה
בן סיני זה מה שנקרא הלכה למשה בן סיני
אוקיי נמשיך כי זה מה שנקרא
>> תקרא פעם אומר שזה לפי מה שנראה לא יתברך
שעל ידי כן נוכל לוותר
רע
>> וגם שח מתפשט בכל הקו שלו לא בכל הקו קו
>> רק באותה מידה לבד ובאופן כי יש עוזמ זמן
קצת לכל מידה כמה תשאב בלי מוכים הוא כפי
הערך האחיזה שיש בה כך ערך ביטולה
>> ברור
>> למה היום הראשון של פסח נקרא יום טוב כי
ביטלנו משהו מאוד גדול למה החולם נקרא
חולם יומים של קדושה כי בצלנו הרבה קליפה
אוקיי נמשיך עכשיו למה נקרא יום עצמאות
כי ביצלנו קליפה קשה מאוד
>> למה נקרא לג בעומר ביטלנו קליפה קשה מאוד
למה נקרא פסח שני ביטלנו קליפה קשה מאוד
לא למה נקרא ראש חודש ביטלנו קליפה גדולה
מאוד ראש חודש סיבה נכון לגמרא אומר
מסכימים יום ירושלים מישה לו משהו גדול
בשביל זה זה יום טוב
זה כתוב כאן כפי ערך הביטול כך ערך קרא זה
מה שכותב כאן
כן כפי אחי זה מתעסק במשהו שתכף תראו מה
זה אתה מתעסק בו בגדול ברגע שאתה מעצים
אותו נעשה משהו טוב אז זה שלילי עוד אור
רע
חס וחלילה זה לא שלילי זה כל זה שג גד הרב
בסדר
>> לאחר שהמצאציל העליון העריך הערכים אלו
בסדר המשכת המוכים בסדר המוכים
>> המשכת המוכים כפי מה שנראה בעיניו יתברך
שעל ידי כך נוכל לבטל אחיזת הקליה על ידי
סדר זה לא פחות ולא יותר
>> אוקיי אז מה אומר הרב אם כן מי זה ערב
בליבו
>> גם אחי אפשר לבטלם אם כן מי זה ערב ליבו
בסדר כוונת התפילות שהם מסודרים שרמות
השנה לכבנה יש סדר הכבנת התפילות והמצוות
והתורה זה מיוחד ישר עם עוד השנה. מה
ההבדל בין ישאר עמוד השנה לבין עכשיו?
קוראים את הציור הזמני.
זה ההבדל.
מה ההבדל? כל השנה כולה אתה בחוץ.
אוקיי? בפסחתה בפנים.
אוקיי? עוד דקה. תראו מה זה בפנים.
>> אבל לכאורה זאת מציאות מתוקנת יותר בחוץ.
שבחוץ זה מתוקן. לכן כל השנה כולה אין לך
בעיה. אתה מכוון כל התפילות, כל הכוונות,
אין לך שום בעיה. אבל בימים אלו הם שונים
במים שונים שאתה לא נמצא מחוץ לקליפה אתה
בתוך הקליפה
לכאורה מצב על הפנים נכון נכון לרגע זה
עוד דקה ת זה לא נכון הלאה
נקרא
בוודאי שזה עוונו ישא כי את קדוש השם חילל
לתת אחיזה לחיצונים בקדושה פוגם בנרן שלו
בכל תפילותיו ותורתו מצוותיו מעשיו הטובים
שיעשה בכל השנה וכולם שחלה מי שמכב כבדות
של התפילה אבל הוא רוצה דביקות בהשם יתבר
הוא מכוון ממשיך מוכים התבקות בשם יתברך
קש עושה ייחודים קשם יתברך שנייה צקנו אתה
לא נדק בשם יתברך צודים יהיה לךשכים
>> הלאה ברור זה לא כללים שלנו זה כללים
שכתבו רבותינו אז איפה כתב הארי לא לכבן
בימים האלה הוא כתב כל ימים האלה נקרא
מוכים לקדנות זה מה שהוא אמר הארי אתה
יודע מה זה מוכן לקדנות לא אז זה מה שאומר
הארי כל ממת ימים האלה הם מוכים לקדנות
אתה מבין זה הם מוכים לקדנות עוד דקה
יסביר סתכלו עוד דקה הוא יסביר הלאה
כי חשכים כיוון כ התייחזו בהם כיוון שנתן
להם יד בימים אלו כי פסח וימים אלו הם
שורש את יכול לראות את השנה
>> הבנו מה זה שורש אתם יודעים מה זה שורש
זוכרים מה זה שורש אז בוא נכתוב
>> פסח פסח
נכון פסח
נכתוב פסח פסח זה שורש
>> שורש
בוא נכתוב מט ימים של ספירת העומר זה מט
שרשים שמשפיעים כל השנה כולה אז בעל ממה
אתה עוסק? בשורש. מה זה שורש?
מה זה שורש?
אתם לא יודעים מה זה שורש?
>> שורש נמצות
אחת. נכון יש הרבה אפשרויות בנר שלום. יש
הרבה אפשרות שורש אנחנו נתוב שורש במושגים
של הרשש
חלק מהשגלה.
אוקיי? מבינים את הראש. אז בעצם מה יוצא?
בוא נעשה כאן עיגולים. נעשה עיגולים בצבת
חלם. בוא נעשה עיגולים בצבת חלם.
בוא נעשה עיגולים בצבת תכלית נעשה כמה
עיגולים בצבת תכלית רואים אז בעצם זה
העיגול הראשון הוא שיך לשבוע הראשון שחודש
נסר
מנגול הראשון שליך לשבוע הראשון העיגול
השני לשבוע השני עיגול השלישי עיגול
הרביעי עיגול החמישי עיגול השישי עיגול
השביעי כל שבוע יש לו עיגול שאנחנו עוסקים
בסתמר 49 שבועות נתקנים עכשיו
איך קוראים לעיגול הזה? קטנות שאנחנו
עדיין לא יודעים על זה נכון? עדיין לא
יודעים על זה מה זה נקרא קטנות אז יש לנו
49 ימים חוץ מפסח שהם שורוש לכל ימות השנה
סגור
מסכימים? אז מה זה ספירת העומר? אתה עוסק
בשורש. בשורש זה לא דבר רע. זה הכי עליון
שיש בעולם. בגלל שאדם מתסק בשורש זה דבר
הכי עליון.
אז לכן מי רוצה להתאחר שם? הקליפה. כי זה
המקום היחיד שהקליפה לא נכנסה לו. למרות
שזה נמצא בקליפה והיו לא בתוך זה. הבנת וד
ההבדל. זה לא סכות רב. תראו.
אוקיי, נקרא. נמשיך הלאה.
>> למה השורש נמצא בתפה?
>> אה,
>> למה השורש
>> זה נקרא קטנות? מה זה כת עכשיו לנו הלה
לאט לאט עוד דקה נתקדם
>> שהולך בהם בא מולכים אותו כל יום אותו שנה
אפילו שבת החמורה נתבטלו עליותיה ב
>> ברור למה בשבת אין נקבלות העליות העולמות
>> למה נתבטלו עליות
כך תראו הלא
>> בין עליית העולמות והמשכת המוחים כישר השם
תותו דמי השנה שהרי כתב כי עדיין הזה הוא
בסוד קטנות כ
>> ברוך שהזה בסוד קטנות אומר זה נכתוב זה
בסוד קטנות
זה בסוד קטנות לכן כן לא מכוונים בתפילות
ובמצוות
לא בקבלת שבת
נכון בקבלת שבת לא במנחת ערב שבת
>> לא מכוונים כלום נכון כי עדיין עזב סוד
קטנות זה מה שכותב הרב מה זה קטנו כבוד
הרב סבלנות תסביר לך
מה זה קטנות כל ה9 בקטנות אז מסביר הרב
לאט אז צריך מסביר לאטה מי לך
>> ואם היה עולה כשארש שבתות היו עולים הכלים
שלו מלבישים הארות יעשו
>> בוא נעשה סף קול בוא נעשה דם חדש סף קול
בוא נעשה סף קול נכון מכירים מוכים ראשיים
>> כן
>> בוא נעשה זה ונוקבה רואים ספקול
זהב ונוקבה
זהב ונוקבה נכון נעשה ככה יסות אבא ואמא
באריך באלכסון או נעשה אלכסון יסות קוביה
אבא ואמא
הנה נעשה אחד עוד אחד באלכסון עוד אחד
באיך קוראים לזה יסות אבא ואמא וארך נכון
מסכימים מוכן ראשים בסבא שלנו מוכן ראשים
בוא נעשה מעלזה שלוש קוביות
אוקיי בוא נעשה מעלזה שלוש קוביות
אוקיי בוא נעשה שלוש קוביות מעלזה
אחד קוביה אחת מי עליה עוד קוביה מעליה
עוד קוביה נכון זה מכירים אותו מקבל מוחים
ראשיים.
>> אוקיי. כמה כלים יש בתוך כל מוח ראשי?
שלושה. זוכרים? בוא נעשה שלושה כלים
מדורגים. אחד.
בוא נעשה שלושה כלים. 1 2 3. כן. יאללה. 1
2 3. בוא נעשה בייסות. 1 2 3. אוקיי. מה
יש בכל אחד? שלושה כלים. בוא נעשה. איפה
הנפש?
בכלי החיצון. מה נכנס בתוך הכלי החיצון?
נרם ונפש. זוכרים חיה חידה מקיב זוכרים?
בוא נעבור לאמצעי.
נרם
ברוח חיה יחידה מקיפים. בוא נעבור לפנימה
שלנו. נרם בנשמה חי מקיפה החיה ביחידה
בתוך.
נכון זוכרים מוכין ראשים זוכרים? חיה
יחידה בתוך הנשמה בתוך הזה נכון? ולמקיפים
זוכרים? זה סף קול. אוקיי? אז אומר הרב
בוא נכתוב בצד בוא נכתוב בצד. כותב הרשש,
אם היינו מכוונים תפילות, נעשה תפילות אם
היינו מכוונים בתפילות, מה היינו עושים?
ממשיכים נרנחי את דיסות אבא ואמא ואריך
היינו מחבים נרנחה דיסות אבא ואמא אריך
לתוך ג' כלים שלהם,
>> נכון? תוך ג' הכלים. איך נקרא מצב זה?
גדלות.
>> גדלות. כתוב גדלות.
>> לזה קוראים גדלות. בוא נקרא. ואם היינו
מכוונים בשבת, אם היינו מכוונים בשבת,
איך אם היינו מכוונים בשבת,
בוא נעשה מה זה כוונות שבת?
לוחים את הכלים, זוכרים כלים? איפה נמצאים
הכלים? בנהי, מעלים אותם לאיפה? בוא
נכתוב. אם היינו מכבלים בשבת, הינו לוקחים
את הכלי הפנימי, מלבשים חבה דנפש.
מה זה חבא דנפש? יחידה.
כן. כלי נמצא פה מלבישים אותו בחיה זוכרים
מה זה חיה חג
>> כן
>> ואת כל נרה נפנו שמים אותו בכלי חיצו
רואים את זה מה זה גורם הדבר הזה מה גורם
העלייה הזאת גורמת לעולמות לעלות ממקומם
חגד נפש
>> חגדי נפש הם צעי נרנחי דרוח
נכון והפנימי נרנחי דנחי
אוקיי אז מה קורה בשבת לכתוב בשבת
בשבת
בשבת אין אור מקיף.
אין אור מקיף.
למה נכתוב למה? מדוע כי כל האורות בתוך
השלושה כלים.
סגור.
זה מה שאומר הרב בעץ חיים שזה מאפשר עליית
העולמות. בנר. למה אפשר להיות במנחת ערב
שבת? כי הכלי עולה לכתר. כדר דיני הבנתם
בגלל שהכלי הפנימי עולדר דיני מה התחילים
העולמות לעלות הבנתם מה שכתוב כאן זה דברי
הרב מה זה נקרא קטנות תגידו מה זה נקרא
קטנות
שני דברים אחד אין לךנחה שנמשכים צד לב
בתוך השלושה כלים אין לך כזה דבר ודבר שני
הכלים לא מתעלים אז איפה זה כתנות איפה
נכבש אותו למטה מים איפה נכבש אותו בנרן
עוד דקה תראו איפה זה בנרן רואים מה ש
אומר מה זה נקרא קטנות זה לא שם אלוהים
הדנות קדתם זה לא נכון בכלל זה המוחין
נמצאים למטה אוקיי בוא נקרא מה אומר סתכלו
ובים היו עולים הכלים שלו מלבישים הכלים
שלו מלבישים האורות דיסות הכלים החיצוניים
שלו ילבישו לאורות הנפש באמצעים לאורות
הרוח ופנימיים לאורות הנשמה
>> ובתוך הנשמה התלבשו אורות החיה ויח רואים
שזה סף כל מוחרשי
>> כן אוקיי נמשיך הלאה
>> דברות הנפש תלבשו בכלים חיצוניים היינו
בכל ה ספירות
>> כל ה ספירות חרד כל הותפש בפנים הכל הכל
אין מקיף והרוח אין מקיף והנשמה אין מקיף
מסכימים
>> וכן באבא ואמא הנשמה וכן ואחר כך וכן אחר
כך יעלו הכלים וילבישו שלא וילבישו להורות
נרנחה את אבא ואמא אלאין הדרך הנזל ממש
וכן כאשר עולה עולה לדייקנה דאריך
ממש הוא עולה הוא עולה
>> אם אתה מכוון בשבת אתה אומר אני מכוון
עכשיו בספירת העומר בשבת
>> אוקיי אז מה אתה מכוון אתה מכוון מוכים
לגדלות אבל הרב אומר שכל הימים זה קדלות
>> גם שבת אז לא אם זה כדות או גדלות אם אתה
מכוון
אם אתה מכוון זה כטות או גדלות זה גדלות
אבל הרב אומר שמ כלבת ימים זה קטנות לא
סגור בוא נקרא ואם כך הנ ואם ככה הוא
שעולה הרי בעליתו להלביש אורות לאסות וכבר
היה לו גדלות אחדות
>> וכן לתולי אבא ואמא ואם כן יאח כתב כי כל
הייחוד שבאותם השבתות איננו איכוד גמור של
גדלות
>> מה איך אתה חושב שזה איחוד קדלות אם אתה
אומר שאני מכבנות שבת לפי דבריך שאומרים
כולם לכוון כוונות שבת אבל אם נכוון
כוונות שבת אז זה גדלות הרב אומר שהאיכות
אשר הותר לנו בשבתות וימים טובים וחול
המון זה פסח שותהר זה קטנות כן ומת יהיה
גדלות חג השבועות אבל אם אתה אומר שאנחנו
מכוונים ביום הרגיל בתפילה ואנחנו מכוונים
גם בשבת אז למה זה נקרא קטנות
אם כן מה שמע רואים
>> כי עדיין זה בסוד הקטנות עד חג השבועות
ואז הוא איחוד גמור לגדלות
>> גדלות נכון סגור כתוב הנה הוכחה הורחה
נוקאט בוא נקרא אז מה זה קטנות ואם כפי
הנזכר הרי כבר יש לו אפילו גדלות ב בכל
היו ספירות אלא אלא ודאי כד
>> שאינם עולים
>> שאינם עולים נכון הכלים לא עולים
>> וזה פשוט וזה היה פה פשולר כל כך שרך כך
מבינים לכן
פשוט וכל כך היה פשוט לרב זל שכך אנחנו
מבינים עד שחשמה לאסור עלינו מצוות עונה
>> מה הקשר בין העונה לבין זה
מה הקשר של מצד העונה
אומר הרב שיש מוכין לקטנ דף פו חלק השני
של עץ חיים פו עמוד דד שכל מקום שיש מוכין
לעיבור ויניקה שזה מוכים לקטנות אסור
להנחם עם האישה תסתכלו פה וא
>> דגדלות
חלילה שכל פעם שיש מוכן בקטנות עיבור
ויניקה אסור להחד עם האישה למה כי נחזים
הקליפה קרועזר בספירת
>> סבדנות הלאה קודם כל תראה מה כתוב תראה מה
לא כתוב הלאה סבדנות זה ההבדל בין מלמד
לבין יריות הלאה בסדר
רגע רגע
>> אוקיי קרו פ עמוד ד פז קרו
>> חלק השני נופ
>> חלק השני החלק השני של
>> חלק השני עמודה
>> ד שמה למטה הגז השמש נכון יש למטה
פז יש
>> פז
>> כן תראו מה כתוב שם פז עמוד למטה מה כדור
>> מזה יובע
>> הלה מזה יובע
>> זה יובל חומר איסור איכות קודם חצות והיות
הזר מבחינת ניקה ועוד בו אחיזת החיציתים
בפ
>> ברור שזה עיבו וניקה יש לך זה לקליפה לכן
אסור אז אתה אומר שמה אתה אומר שבימים
האלה זה בסוד קטנות עיבור והיאקה אז אם זה
עיבור והיאניקה אז אסור ברור סגור או לא
אז איך הארי מתיר תגרו מה אומר הרב
>> חוזרים אנחנו לב עמוד ג למטה חזרנו חזרנו
נכון בוא נקרא ואם כפי הנזל
>> אם כפי הנזל הרי כבר יש לו אפילו גדלות
דבר בכל צפירות אלא ודאי כדמרן שאינם
עולים וזה פשוט וכל כך היה פשוט לרב לרב
זל שכך אנחנו מבינים עד שחשש שם הנאסור
עלינו מצוות עונה בראותינו כי שבתות אלו
נשתנו משאר שבתות שאין בהם עלייה לזון
ולעולמות על ידי התפילות והם אוכלים
לגדלות בני עד
>> מה זה גדלות או קטנות
>> גדלות בניי לא הבנת מה זה גדלות בניג
>> אתה אומר קטנות לא
>> הבנת מה שכתוב כאן אז בוא נעשה נעשה מלבה
בוא נעשה מלב נעשה מלבן נעשה מלבן עומד
לחלק אותו לחבד חג התנאי חבד לחלק אותו
לחבד חבד חג התנאי בסדר חבד
חגתי אוקיי בוא נחתי לחבר חגתני חגתי
אוקיי אז בוא נכתוב בצד השמאלי נכתוב כל
הקוביה העליונה קוראים לה חבד רואים כל
הקוביה העליונה קוראים לה חבל עליונה קצת
שמאל יכתוב הלאה חב חב חב
חבב
חב נכון איך קוראים ל קובי המסע חגה נכתוב
בצד קבלת שבת
אוקיי בוא נכתוב למטה איך קוראים לה
קובייה התחתונה נהי
נהי אוקיי נכתוב נהי בוא נעבור לנאים יש
לו שלושה כלים נעשה שלושה כלים מדורגים
למטה למטה אחרון שלושה כלים אחד בתוכו 1 2
3 אוקיי איך קוראים לזה ני דליני תכתוב
בצד ני דני ני דני מה זה ני דני שמע מה זה
שמע שחר מנחה וערבי מה עושה הכהן
חבד חג נכון תכתוב ברכה
>> כן
>> חגד חבד ברכה תכתוב ברכה על כתוב על שלם
ברכה מה זה ברכה
ברכת כהנים
>> נכון זה עושה כהן גדול כהן שלנו עושה בוא
נעשה כדרס למנחת ערב שבת זוכרים כן
כתר דיניים זה מנחת ערב שבת אתם כבר
יודעים את זה לא ככהנו חלק ג איפה מצרים
בכוספיר אתה אומר
תכל מצרים רואים את הנאי הזה אנחנו נמצאים
בני שלו הנאי הזה של שחרי מלחית אנחנו
נמצאים אפילו בני שלו למטה
>> אפילו לא בני הכללי אם היה הני הכללי
מכוונים כל התפילות איפה נמצאים נכתוב
ניקח את הני הזה נעשה אותו גדול נעשה את
הני דניאי נכתוב כותרת ני דני נעשה אותו
גדול כן נעשה נעשה את הני דני נעשה אותו
גדול בצד השמאלי נעשה ציור ני דניאי נכון
בוא נחלק אותו לשלושה חלקים
אחד שתיים נכון אז אם נכתוב נהי דני בצד
ימין נכתוב בצד ימין נהי דני נכתוב בצד
ימין ימין נהי דני למעלה כותרת נהי דניאי
נהי דניאי בסדר מה יש לו חבד חבד לכתוב
חבד
חגתנאי נכון אז מה אנחנו עושים כל השנה
כולה מתחילים נהי דניאי זה התפילה נכון
תפילה תכתוב למטה ני דני תפילה למטה בצד
ימין נכתוב ני דניאי תפילה תפילה נכון
איפה מתקדמים אחר כך לחג לא בתפילה לח זה
תפילה חג חמה זה תפילה שלושת אלה זה תפילה
נכון שלושה חלקים בתפילה קטנות גדלות אבל
כל זה איפה זה נמצא בני או עם ני דני איפה
אתה נמצא בספרת העומר למשה בני דני אפילו
להתפלל לךמוכים
אוקיי הבנת מה שכתוב כאן אתה נמצא מוכין
לגדות בני דני בני הזה נמצא למטה כל
>> נכון כל זה ני דני נהי דני כל זה נהי דני
נכון זה אתה בונה אותם מתפילה שלושה חלקים
מתחיל בנאי עובר לחג הדני עובר לחבד זה
מפללים שלוש פעמים ביום בא הכהן מוסיף לך
עוד חבד חג הדני נכון הכהן מוסיף עוד עוד
למעלה אז איפה זה נמצא כל הימים האלה בני
דגלות איך קוראים להני דגלות קטנות
מסכימים
זה בכלל לא עיבור וניקה
עיבור
>> זה לא עיבור ולא איניקה חז וחלילה
>> כן בוא נעשה שלושה קווים
>> זה בקו השלישי כל זה לא עיבור
>> נכון כזה חלילה הלאה
רואים רואים את השלושה הקווים האלה איפה
אתה נמצא בקו הפנימי
אתה נמצא בקו גדלות אתה לא נמצא בריבור
ונקרא בשני הקבים החיצים אתה נמצא בקרב
הפנימי
מסכימים
>> אה גובני נקרא זה ה
>> זה זה יש קבחציון מצי אתה לא מזל קו חציון
אתה נמצא הכלי הפנימי
מה יש בי הפנימי הזה יש לו חג שנמשכים
נשמת כל חי חגד קבלת שבת מה היא שלוש
תפילות שזה כל גם ברכת כהנים איפה אתה
נמצא עכשיו אתה לא נמצא באבוריניק אתה לא
נמצא בקטנות הזה זה לא ההגדרה של קטנות
אתה נמצא איפה אתה נמצא בני דני כל ספירת
נמצא ני דני מה אתה מושים לו חבד חג נכון
אבל יש בעיה בוא נעשה עיגולים שחור בתוך
זה בוא נעשה עיגול שחור בתוך זה בני דן
אעשה עיגול שחור
כן נעשה עיגול שחור ותכו נעשה חלב
אז מה אתה עושה בספרת עובר אתה עובד
בעיגול הפנימי הזה
מה אתה עושה באנו חושך לגרש איך קוראים
למצר של בלבנו
>> שגתרי
>> לא לגרש את החושך לא
>> איך קוראים לו איך קוראים לו זה רואים
שמקובלים עליו מקובלים עלה מה נחזור עוד
פעם יש פה באים ששרשים יבנה שעליהם ימשך
יבנה כל הבניין בהמשך השנה מה יש לנו שמה
בתוך הנאי דניאי אז זה יש לנו קליפה נכון
אז בוא נתעסק בתוך הפנימי בוא נעצים את
הפנימי בוא נכתוב העיגול הזה הפנימי בוא
נעצים אותו איך הוא נקרא מוכים מקטנות איך
קוראים לזה צגרימית
יש משהו בתוך הסיפור הזה משהו מאוד גדול
אז החיצונים רוצים לתקוע את זה למה כי
ברגש לוקעים את זה כל השנה תקועה
הבנתם מה מה הפשט? אז בוא נעשה יום הראשון
מה אנחנו עושים מעצימים את התכלת ממנה
קליפה עפה החוצה יבם לא שנחזר חס וחלילה
אנחנו כל יום מספירת יום שלוש שני שלישי
רבי חמישי נמצאים בתכלת הזה שנקרא שורש
ואנחנו מעצים איפה הוא נמצא השורש לא נמצא
למעלה הוא נמצא למטה למטה עמוק עמוק
הבנתם הבנתם מה שאומר הרב לזה קוראים
מוחים דקטנות כבוד הרב זה מוכים כן זה
נקרא מוחים דקטנות או קוראים לזה מוחים
לגדות בני
מה שאומר הרב אז בעצם מה אתה עושה אתה
מתעסק בני דיני והשורש הפנימי הזה אתה
הולך להעצים אותו אוקיי איך אתה מעצים
אותו אז אומר הרב ליגוע בו באופן ישיר זה
מסובך אז בוא נעשה לו מה נעשה הגנה נכון
מה נעשה ככד חגד זה ספירת העומר וברגע
שאתה עובד בחגד חגד למעלה אלה שני אלה
רואים אותם אתה יורד לשורש
אדם יורד לשורש עכשיו אומר היום יום אחד
לעומר היום שבעה ימים לעומר שם שבוע אחד
אתה מגיע לשורש זה מה שכותב הרב
הבנתם
למה רק חבד חג זה סתומר
>> זה ספת העומר מה עושים כל יום חבת חגתם לא
פסבים חבד חגדם מי זה חבת חגדם זה החלק
העליון אז למה לא מחבלים בתפילה כי אתה
מכין תשתיק כדי להתפלל צריך שיהיה השורש
נקי מבריק השורש לא מבריק
נכון זה מה שגיד הרב שאתה מה עושה בוא
נעשה היום יום אחד לא אומר בוא נמחק את
הכל קליפה אין לא נוגעים בקליפה הבנו אף
החוצה אז מה עשינו שורש אחד מוכן שנבוא
בשבוע הראשון של חודש ניסן נתחיל לכוון
הכל כל למה כי יש לנו את הבסיס עולים
למעלה סגור
>> שבוע של חודש
>> שבוע הראשון של ניסן נכון
>> לא שבוע הראשון של ניסן כל יום זה כנגד
שבוע נכון נפ יום שני ימים לעומר שבוע שני
של חודש ניסן שנה הבאה עם סלה הלאה בסדר
שבוע שליש שלישי יום שלישי שבוע רביעי
>> אוקיי הבנתי זה מה שכותב הרב ככה מתחילים
אז מתקלים עכשיו ארבעה שבורות שניסן
מהלילה נתחיל אייר סיבה נכון נתחיל יה
סיבה רק נעשה תמוז אב אלוז נחזור עוד פעם
אז עכשיו אז מה אנחנו עושים עכשיו נהנים
שנה שעברה לא מה שעשינו מספרת אומר שנה
שעברה עכשיו זה עובד עלינו הלאה סגור לזה
קוראים פנים סתם ככה זה מה שכותב הרב סגו
זה מה שכותב אומר
בוא נקרא מה שומר הרשע שלמה אתם רואים וזה
נקרא מורכים לגדלות בנה היא אומר מה אתה
חשבת שלמה אסור מצוות עונה כי זה עיבור ו
נקרא לא זה לא עיבור ו נקרא זה לא מה
שכתוב בדף פז זה מדובר על הגדלות בפנים
הכתול מדובר על הבפנים על הכלי הפנימי לא
כלי אמצעי וחצון הבנתם
הבנתם זה לא מדובר על הכלי החיצון ואמצעי
סגור
הבנתם מה שאומר הרב
>> אהחציו
לא שחר זה גם עיבור וניקה זה גם בשחר
עושים את זה זאת אומרת העיבור וניקה הזה
שאתה מדבר עליו כל יום שזה אסור איחוד
נכון כי זה זה עיבור וניקה של המוח הראשי
נר נחי דנפש נרנחי דרוע אבל זה לא בנר נחי
דנפש זה ביןחי דנחי של יסות של אבמה של
אריך איבנר אז איפה נמצא הקטנות לא בעיבור
והיא נקרא הוא נמצא בפנים בגדלות איפה הוא
נמצא בני דיני מה יש בני דיני יש שורש
נכון יש שורש אז ברגע שאתה עושה כבר שורש
זה העיקר
הכוונה שאם יש לך שורש יש לך כל הכבות
לבנות על זה. אז אם יש לך שורש ביום
הראשון אז יש לך שבוע ראשון שנה הבאה
בחודש ניסן אתה יכול לכוון יש לך שבוע שני
שבוע שלישי שבועי חמישי השלישי יש לך מה
לכוון אוקיי סגורי בנרקנו
שנחסים להם יסוד אבא ואמא
>> זה זה קשורש איפה נקרא בוא תעבור לציור
הראשו של הסף קול בוא נעבור ציור הספקול
בוא נקרא סף קול בוא נעשה איפה עשינו ימים
א'ב איפה נמצאים בכלי הפנימי של יסוד
איפה נמצאים בימים
ג ד וז איפה אתה נמצא ואבא ואמא לא
איפה נמצא בוא נגיד אלי אה
>> זה מה שומר
>> בעבר
>> זה מה שאומר הרב
>> ברור לכם מה שכתוב כאן אז כתוב זה אבלות
זה על הפנים זה לא נכון זה פשוט לא נכון
זה מה שכותב הרשש אה עושים את האמצע
>> לא עושים בימים האלה אסור
אין לא מתעסקים בהם בכלל
בימים רגילים
>> בימים רגילים זה נקרא חורבן הבית
שמתעסקים בחורבן הבית או בהסתלקות המוחין
אתה מסכים בעיבור ביניקה אבל בימים האלה
כזה דבר העיבור בניקה האלה שלמים שלמים
תחשוב כמוני שלמים ישתבח שמו לעד בלי אז
אין דיקון חצאות אין בכי אין כלום
ככה שאם יש לך עבודה באיבור וניקה אז יש
לך חצות לילה ויש לך בחייה לחורבן כי זה
הסיבה נכון כאילו כף היית עמוד ב
>> אז לפי המרכוא כן אם ככה
>> לפי המחו כן לפי זה לפי המחו
>> המחו בסדר אבל תלמיד חכם לא הסתיר זה המחו
>> בסדר הזמרתי לך שזה אתה מבין שזה ככה כן
אז תעזור שהסתיר זה לא הסתיר הלאה זה סתם
סיפורים הלאה מה הסתיר מה אתה מבין בכלל
הלאה נמשיך הלאה רואים תסתכלו
סתכלו יחד קרו מה שאומר הרב סתכלו זה מה
שכותב בדף כח סתכלו אומר שספירת אומר גלות
מצרים הוא עיבור ונקרא בנשמה מה
תסתכלו כח רואים כח חלק שני שלחים כח עמוד
ב איך אומר תכלו אומר מה שחוזר ז לכתון
ראשון גם לעיבור כגון בחורבן הבית
>> או בפסח זה עיבור וניקה עיבור וניקה דנשמה
אבל אומר הרשש תשמע נכון שעיבור וניקה זה
על הפנים בימי ספירת העומר הוא מושלם
הוא מושלם אין לך אין לך מה לפחד למה הוא
מושלם בגלל בגל שאתה נמצא בני דנה אתה
עובד בשורש אז ברגע שאתה עובד בשורש שאתה
מתקן אותו אתה מעיף את כל הקליפה החוצה
אוקיי אז אם עכשיו י את כל הקליפה החוצה
בוא נחזור כוח עכשיו קוראים לך קצת מילה
יש לך מקום להגיד תיקור אחר אין לך יש לך
לבטל קליפה אין קליפה אין כלום
בגלל שזה סף כל חוכמה או ב
>> אה בלי קשר לחוכמה
>> לא בגלל שזה סף כל חוכמה או ש
>> בגל ש לא בלי קשר לחוכמה רואים זה מה
שכתוב כאן רואים החלק הזה זה מה שומר הרב
בגלל שאנחנו נסכים בני דיני בכלי הפנימי
בני דיני שלו מי תסכים במה בשורש ברגע
שאתה מתקי בסר את אומרת את השורש נכון אתה
לא מכוון בתפילות כי אין לך למעלה אין אין
לך למעלה אבל הפח את השורש נכון אז אם רוח
לשורש אז מה קורה כל הלילה נהפח ליום טוב
וגם היום היום נפח לייום טוב נכון למה כן
לך חזק הקליפה אוקיי אז למה נגיד קורון
חזרות
עובד קגור חזרות בגלל שעיבור וניקר הרוס
אין לך הוא לא הרוס בימים האלה אז איך
הימים האלה אבילות או שמחה ואחים שחיינו
אחים שחיינו מי הלך לברך שחיינו דווקא
פרינציב נגנה עכשיו פרנסיב נגנה עכשיו
נגנה דוק שכנו פרינציב הלאה
>> נעשה פרינציב למה לא לברך שחינו זה לא
אבילות זה לא בטיח הלאה דווקא אני קנה פרי
חדש כדיש שסק עכשיו זה מחפש איזה פרי לא
הכל בחוץ ענבים שזה של החמורים לא
>> שסק ישן יש שסק הרכתי אני ברחתי שפסח שיש
שסק הלאה ברחתי שסק כל פשבת אני אחפש את
זה פרינציפ הלה
פרינציפ יש לי הרבה חולצות לבנות הרבה
תלות חדשות אני כל שבת ברכה כל שבת ברך
למה אני אעשה זה אבילות אומר הרב זה שורש
אם אתה מתקן את השורש אז בעצם כל הקליפה
אף פעם מ למעלה עד למעלה אז אין לך סיבה
לבכות בתיקון חצאות אין לך שום סיבה נכון
בוא נקרא קראו יחד איתי זה לא שומר הרב
למטה רואים לב עמוד בזיים לב עמוד ג למטה
סתכל זה לא שאומר הרב
שורה אחרונה
כי הם מוכים לגדלות בניי לא הבנת זה קטנות
זה גדלות אומר לא מבין את השדה של הרב
קוראים לזה קטנות אבל זה לא עיבור וניקה
זה גדלות בניי למטה למטה בניי למטה אתה
נמצא למטה נו אז נמצא למטה זה על הפנים מה
זה על שם יש לך את הכרטיס אשראי שאתה מקבל
מיליון דולר זה קטן עלינו מיליון שקל הלאה
בכל
הריעד הזה שלהם זה
שלוש הלאה ככה אמרו לא יודע מה זה אומר
הלאה רואים מהפשט אתה מתעסק במשורשי זה מה
שכובר סתכלו
רואים
>> זה רשון לחלק ב
>> אבל אם אתה עכשיו מוסיף לו את דף נח
אתה מוסיף לו את נט הרסת את כל הגיש הרסת
הכל הרסת הרסת הכל מנתם הרסת הכל
בש התייחסות בוא נקרא הרב ז אמת ליעקב בוא
נקרא אמת יעקב בוא נקרא
מה שקרה
אמת בוא נקרא אמת ליעקב נכון נקרא עמודה
א' אחרי שקראינו קב קב
>> עמוד א'
>> כן
>> האמנם
>> זה מה שניסה הרש גם העולמות אז הוא אומר
לא מכבלים לא מכבלים בקבלת במנחת שבת
עולמות למה לא אתה לא נמצא אפילו בכדר
דניי אתה אפילו עניי דני אתה נמצא לא היתח
אפילו כוונות של תפילה הם לך אוקיי אז זה
חיסרון זה לא חיסרון אתה מתעסק בשורש
בשורש שורש שאתה מתזק בשורש זה כל השנה
כולה לפניך אוקיי אז אם זמן לך אוטומט אתה
בא אוטומט שחור אתה
זה לא נכון סתכלו זה מה שכ דבר סכלו קרא
>> הם ספר ספר הזמרת הארץ הזכיר דבריו
>> נכון אז זה תלמידים שלא חלקו עליו
>> שריך רכיב בעניין זה והביא ראיות נכונות
ברורות וישרות זה צריך בכל הימים
>> מסכימים
>> אז מה צריכים לכוון אם כתוב צריכים לכוון
אתה לא יבינו לרבה של שבת
סוף דורב כתב ושומע לו שכון בטח
>> נכון אז מה הם אומרים שאומרים שהרב דברת
הרב תורת חכם מגן זה דוד מג'ר וכולי וכולי
הוכיחו בתות מופתים שהרש טועה אני אשאל
אותך כבוד הרב תסביר לי מילה אחת מה זה
נקרא כל ממית ימים האלה ימי כתוב תן לי
פירוש יש לך פירוש תן לי פירוש שגע בשבת
זה ימי כתנות מה זה תגיד מה
מה זה מקטנות? נחזור למהחלה רואים? בהתחלה
בוא נקרא דף הראשון שהסבר לכם על זה קטנות
בוא נעשה איקסים הדף הראשון שכתבנו שהצגנו
את השאלה רואים בואו נציג את השאלה רואים
את השאלה שהצגנו אותה
הנה דף הראשון רואים
>> רואים כולנו נכונות
לקח רונה
מהמרה כל האפשרות שלמה לא נכונות
כל שלו נכונות
רק אחרונה נכונה זה מה שכותב הרשש
>> אוקיי אני לכם שיעורי ביתנו
>> שיעורי בית בשביל שבוע הבא שיעורי בית
נכתוב שיעורי בית לחפש מי זה השורש הזה
איזה שורש מדבר הרב שאח מתעסקים בו כל
הימים האלה
>> איפה לחפש
>> איפה שאתה עושה
תחפש
>> שמונה שעה יש לך למדתם אצלי למדתם הראתי
לכם תיא יבתי לכם לו לדעתי לכם הרבה לא
קראתי לכם הרבה לז עמוד דראתי לכם הרבה
מקומות לא חפשו עכשיו פירוש מה זה שורש
עוד אחד
>> כן מה זה שורש שעומדים עליו בימים האלה אז
אנחנו מקבילים את החשיבה למה כי זה מדובר
על ספקוד
לא שבירה בתיקון
שבירה בתיקון חס וחלילה אוקיי אז תחפשו מי
זה השורש הזה א נכתוב מה ההבדל בין השורש
של פס פסע. מה ההבדל בין השורש של פסח
לשורש של מט ימים ספירת העומר ובין השורש
של חג השבועות? זה לא אותם שחשים
נכון? מי שיוציא צבעוני צמחוני יודע מה זה
ששים אוקיי?
>> אוכל שורשים
>> אוכל שרשים כל הזמן אוכל שרשים רואים אז
מה ההבדל בין השרשים? מה ההבדל בין זה לזה
לזה?
סגור איבנו
אז זה שורי בית
שבוע ב נסביר את זה רואים זה מה שכותב הרב
כ אתה עוסק בשורש אבל השורש הוא בפנים
עמוק הוא לא למעלה הוא לא שאיפה כלפי מעלה
הוא המנגנון התחתון שדרכו עפים אז אומר
הרב בסבירת העומר תשמע בספירת העומר אין
לך חטאים תודה רב למה אין לך חטאים לכן
ייחודים כי כל הייחודים זה להסיר טומאה
ייחוד החברתי זה הרי
סגור עם הפנים. אייחוד ה החותם זה יסודנו
פגום. נכון? כל הייחודים זה רק פגמים.
אומר לך תשמע, בימים האלה אין פגמים, אין
תיקון חצות, אין כלום. ריק. הכל ריק. הכל
מהעולה. סגור.
>> אז כל הכוונות הייחודים שייכים במציאות
תגומה.
>> אפילו מציאות כוונות ריחודים.
>> נכון? אין כזה דבר.
אוקיי.
מסכימים? אני גם בשבת. אה
>> מכוונים בשבת
>> בשבת לא מכוונים כלום מה מכבלים
>> לא ייחודים מה לא בבל בכול
>> באיכול הם מה מחבלים בשבת
>> עושים חברתה עושים אה
>> רק חברתי זה אלוה ק זה מה שנשאר לך ואחד
השם מתקרב מה עושים זה בסדר הלאה
אתנו אז זה דין חכמי בית שלא עוברים תיקון
נעה במשבת בסדר ניתן
מה נעשה אוקיי הרב ששש כתב עלינו ככה לא
בסדר ככה כתב עלינו הלאה כתבו לד הוא כמו
רמון חי
אוקיי נמשיך זה מה שאומר הרב זה מה שניסרש
להסביר הוא לא הצמח בישיבה הוא לא הצמח
בישיבה לא הצמח לא הצמיח
למה כולם שמעו קטנות קליפה קליפה קליפה
קליפה אומר להם תשמע מה שאני אומר לך תחכה
עם הקליפה שלך כל כך תשמע מה אומר הרב הרב
במצג בשרשים בזה השרשים לא נפגמו ברגע שלא
נפגמו אז אתה מבין שאתה עוסק במשהו מאוד
עצוב שברגע שיש לך את השורש ביד הזה זה על
זה נבנים הכוונות אבל אם אין לך שורש אין
לך שורש אין לך כלום אוקיי ככה אומרים
בישיבות מה זה נקרא ביטול תנאי אחד עשה
קניין שעכשיו הוא בא לבטל את התנאי עכשיו
אני מבטל את העסק מה זה נקרא זה בניין
שהיה קיים
והוא נהר או בכלל לא בנית נכון ככה אומרים
בישיבות אחד קוראים לו הרב שמעון שקופ ככה
אומר אומר מה הפשט שמים דינמית מתחת
לבניין
שמים חומר נפץ אם אתה משלם כסף הבינה שלך
אם לא לוחץ על הכפתור הורס הבינה נכון
עיין לערך רק עשה מה שעשו לנו מחשמוזח מה
שעשו לנו הרשו את כל הבניין נכון זה לא
מבפנים אז ככה הוא כותב אומר ביטול תנאים
בכל השס ככה הוא כותב הרב רב שמעון שקוב
ככה כותב שהביטול תנאים בכל השוונה
שמציאות לא שלא קיימת בכלל אלא מבטלים
אותה בסדר בוא נוסיף לו לא אנחנו פרט קטן
זה לא מדויק
כי ביסוד יהיה שורש טוב
שאתה הורס אתה הורס שרה וזה מה שכתוב
בביטול תנאים בכל השדם
אם אחד מוכר בית ולא קנו אותו הוא לא הורס
לבית
הוא מוכר למישהו אחר הוא לא הורס הבית
נכון הרב אלחי מורסים אתה נכון אז ההנחת
היסוד שלו לפי מה שאני מסביר לכם היא לא
נכונה
נכון השיעורים שיש בישיבות
זה לא נכון זה לא ביטול תנא שאתה לא מקיים
את התנאים זה לא שאתה מד את המציאות חס
וחלילה במציאות יש שורש גדול שורש אוקיי
אז תראו אני אתן לכם רק רמז לבד שזה נקרא
נשמת ישראל שתמצאת בכל ספירה וספירה
תסתכלו בדף יא עמוד דכתוב שזה נקרא אלה
בכל פרט בפרט זה בזה עוסקים זה השור
שעוסקים בו אוקיי בזה נסיים בטוב תקחו
יא עמוד ד אומר בכל ספירה וספירה שנגלה
רואים ושנגלה נמצא בכל ספירה וספירה בכל
פרסו ופרסוף קרו
>> חלק הראשוני ק
>> אחר כך
>> באופן ששור שנשמה גוב לבוש ובכל 10 ספירות
בכלל בכל יו ספירות בכל פרטי פרצופי
בחצילות הבנת מה כתוב כאן
>> בכל פרט יש לך בכל ספירה יש לך שורש אבל
אני חשבתי ששורש זה משהו למעלה זה אתה
חשבת ואני אין לך זה בפנים בפנים בפנים
אתה מתעסק בשורש בפנים אז כל השנה אתה
בונה על השורש הזה בני בימים האלה אתה
מתעסק בשורש הזה קוראים לשורש הזה נשמת
ישראל אתה בונה אותם
>> בכל ספירות דפרטי ברצ אוקיי לכן הקדוש
ברוך הוא עשה שני ימים טובים דווקא בספירת
העומר פשוט שזה הגיוני אין לך יום אחר
מאשר זה עם הכי מתאים אין לך משהו אחר
אוקיי בוא נחונו לנו עוד כמה ימים חשבנו
פסח לא ככה שום דבר חכו שבועיים
>> בעזרת השיבו בשעתו אמן ברוך אדוני לעולם
אמן ואמן תגדל והתקדש השמא
>> בעמדיבר חירות וימליך מלכות ויצמח קנה
ויקרב משכ
>> אמן
בישראל גלה בזמן קרב אמן
>> אמן שמבחל
יתברך וישתבח ויתברל
שקשה בך
>> אמן